[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13 o'clock
[Music]
hey what's up everybody it's Wednesday
night it's the main show and it's
Thanksgiving Eve at least if you're in
the United States
so hopefully everyone's gonna have a
Happy Thanksgiving tomorrow oh it's
Thanksgiving Eve no matter where you are
in the world they're just not
celebrating it over there okay if you
want to get technical about it
that's the thing I actually okay so I
made um a little bit of an announcement
on the Community page on YouTube all the
I mean we're still going to do the live
streams at the same time but all the
recorded stuff is probably going to be
like a little bit late just because I
got really behind and because of the
holiday and everything like that so you
know normally if you were a patron you
would have already like I would have
already put up like a couple things but
you know we just haven't got around to
doing them yet so you know stuff will be
up but it'll just be like a little bit
later than normal because I'm just kind
of like behind so don't be alarmed a lot
of stuff going on gotta do a lot of
cooking and [ __ ] that's what yeah that's
what I mean I mean I couldn't even cook
for today I had to go out and do you
know Chinese food cooking pies sides
did a bunch of prep work both a couple
days cutting celery and
onions and stuff for the
for the dressing and for stuffing yeah
so but all I gotta do is cook the turkey
tomorrow
we'll see that's that's what it is got a
lot of extras doing a lot of like work
on it
but yeah [ __ ] like yeah we couldn't even
use the kitchen so we had to uh get
Chinese food
but that was like I mean that was a
pretty good deal because it ended up
being like well more than I could eat so
I might eat some more after the show but
yeah I couldn't eat it all can't guys
said I've been assembling casseroles all
day today yeah yeah
that's easy though that's true yeah
great you put the cream of mushroom soup
in it and the damn potato the the uh
fake onion rings we're not fake the
pre-made onion rings on top of it yeah
they're crispy onions yeah you like that
I don't know oh yeah I don't really like
green beans it's a [ __ ] redneck
[ __ ]
redneck [ __ ] Cuisine right there man
that's a
special dish
honestly if I you know
um if I have that everywhere they
probably do that in Australia I would
normally just I'm just like a turkey
potatoes stuffing pumpkin pie type of
girl like if you didn't make any other
[ __ ] other than that that I'd be totally
happy we're gonna we're gonna have
instant mashed potatoes oh I was doing
those tomorrow
I mean that's so man I got so much other
stuff I know yeah but sometimes it's
nice to have like the nice one I don't
have any fresh potatoes yeah oh well
we'll do that Ben says when are the
Indians coming over yeah how you coming
nobody's coming over we're just gonna
eat it all yeah they got their own [ __ ]
they got their own [ __ ] yeah
they asked around I asked around so for
some of our friends if they needed a
place to go they're all they all got
places to go everybody's got places to
go
pretty much well and um you remember
Tiff from ibar yeah she has been for
many many years has always like opened
up her house for anybody that so she
because she announces it like every year
she's been doing that for as long as I
can remember
so which is really nice yeah
um Camp guy said we're doing a wet brine
turkey breast on the Ron Popeil
rotisserie okay um
that dude's not she's not so alive is he
that guy
I thought he was the one out of Hannibal
no he's the one that did all the all the
gadgets from like the The infomercials
and whatnot Weird Al Yankovic wrote a
song about him
did I just kick you in the Oh I thought
I just kicked Pookie in the face because
I was like putting my foot down and I
was like I felt something like behind my
heel I guess it was your foot
um yeah so I probably I was wasn't
really thinking but I was just kind of
like oh I guess we could have done like
a more Thanksgiving adjacent like topic
but I mean there's really not well and
the thing well the thing about it too is
that we've already done I think like
last year or the year before we always
do like American histories type of stuff
like we did like Lost Colony of Roanoke
and all that kind of stuff which isn't
explicitly to do with Thanksgiving but
was kind of like American history
adjacent but and I just couldn't you
know it's like I can't really think of
much of it it's just kind of like CR
when we do the Christmas show it's like
we already did like all the fun
Christmas topics and now I can't think
of [ __ ] you know what I mean so it's
like oh well
Zach says uh he's asking if uh he's
trying to think of something healthy to
order for dinner well we don't know
what's around there so I wouldn't really
know he said my problem with most fast
food isn't how it tastes but it's after
I eat it I feel kind of ill for hours
after eating it yeah um yeah it depends
what it is but
that's the thing like we don't really
have much close by here like I said
other than we don't really even have a
lot of fast food like close by here like
it's some like you know maybe five or
six miles away but there's not there's
nothing really really close like we have
a Chinese place and yeah there's a
Subway like inside the convenience store
but that's gonna be it you know but
other than that it's kind of like more
fancy [ __ ] you know not fancy but you
know Fast Cash privately privately owned
stuff yeah that's not yeah corporate
right that's the thing I mean you could
probably if you called like GrubHub or
something they'd probably bring it to
you but it'd probably be cold by the
time I got here
so
this evening
we'll be talking about one of our
favorite topics Scientology [ __ ] on
the Church of Scientology but more
specifically we want to talk about the
Lisa McPherson case because it struck me
that as many shows as we've done about
scientology and as many times we've
talked about scientology we've never
talked specifically about the Lisa
McPherson case and I thought it was time
to rectify that actually I think
somebody recommended it I was like yeah
why don't we do that because like I said
that's I have like a personal
connection to that because I worked at
the same company that she worked at like
obviously several years later like after
she had died but
um some of the people were still there
from that time and like the woman that
ran the company uh also ran the company
back then it was like Lisa McPherson's
McPherson's boss and she was one of the
people that kind of like oversaw the
whole thing so you know what I mean like
she knew her and everything
so you know it's kind of like I don't
remember a lot of their names I do
remember like the woman's name that uh
that ran the place because it's on the
Wikipedia page
but
um I specifically remember that one of
the sales reps at the company that I
worked for was Lisa McPherson's roommate
at the time but I can't remember what
her [ __ ] name was like I can remember
what she looks like but I can't remember
what her name was because I worked there
the company was called I don't know if
it's still there or not it's called AMC
publishing and um
so I I worked there in like
2001 2002 something like that and Lisa
McPherson died in 1995 but a lot of the
same people were there so that's uh what
that's gonna be all about but yeah it's
just um
this is a pretty [ __ ] up it's a pretty
[ __ ] up story and like I said we we've
done a lot of stuff about scientology so
you know as we go on like talking about
that case specifically
then uh you know we can kind of come in
with
more crazy [ __ ] about scientology Ben
said the top Scientologist wife went
missing didn't she yeah Shelly uh
miscavige no one's seen her in public as
far as I know since about 2007.
um and the thing about it I think when
uh there was a whole thing about uh Leah
Remini because she was friends with her
and after Leah Remini left she was
actually kind of like asking around like
where Shelly was and basically she got
the run around and after she left the
church she kind of got worried so she
went and reported her missing
uh and supposedly the cops went and
investigated but they were like well
she's an adult and we found her and
she's alive and so you know stop talking
about it and um you know and she's not
being held against her will but that's
just what they said so nobody's seen her
since then
um what should we talk about Shelly
Shelly yeah
I think you're talking about Lee uh not
Leah Remini uh [ __ ] uh the girl that
died what's her name again
today Lisa McPherson yeah yeah McPherson
okay yeah yeah no yeah they know where
Shelley is yeah they know where she is
which is like she's probably like in a
[ __ ] dungeon somewhere that's not
where she is
later on I heard where she is she's just
in a real obscure
do-nothing job
like taking charge of a damn library
somewhere what's it called uh
the rim of the earth that that uh oh
yeah whatever they call it yeah it's
that secret Scientology base that's up
in the Sierra Nevada mountains I can't
believe it looks like I can't believe
they really have like this stuff it's
like a [ __ ] super villain yeah it's
like a uh at one time I think it was a
uh like a lodge like a like a camping
Lodge where you know you could rent
Condos for the for vacation it was like
that and then they turned it into a
Scientology secret base with ultra
barrier that goes around it because
it's kind of like kind of like a fence
that's sharp with uh concertina wire
across the top of it there's no way in
or out of it they say it's to keep the
Bears out like yeah right and it's got
motion detectors and cameras if you get
up on that
up on that fence you know what I mean
the uh it detects you and the cameras
zoom in on you
AGP or angry gay Pope who's been on the
show before this is a long time ago we
used to have guests every now and then
uh he did a whole video that they took
down it's gone now I can't find any of
his [ __ ] video stuff I think he moved
some of his stuff to like a different
serve but yeah I gotta ask him about
that well because American Military 100
I just asked if we'd ever invite him
back on the show like last time he
invited him I'd have a bad God he's just
a handful to deal with
it's not so much that it's just that
it's always kind of like a pain in the
ass because the the problems that I have
before were not like with him they were
like technical problems yeah like you
know we we always had like [ __ ] up
sound and like our our sound was [ __ ]
up and his was fine or vice versa and it
was like a pain in the ass like to edit
it back together he doesn't ever want to
really stay on top topic he wants us he
wants to [ __ ] talk what he wants to
talk about he never know what that
dude's going to talk about oh now see
you really don't you don't you don't
have any cause to like get nil over any
other people's kids
though to talk about scientology you
know what I mean he'll [ __ ] go down a
crazy way
um but no I [ __ ] spin [ __ ] which
is hours and hours watching his [ __ ]
when it was when it was on YouTube but
YouTube [ __ ] sank his entire Channel
and that was like all of his income and
everything you know he's not a real rich
guy uh because he lost his job out of
Hollywood he used to work in Hollywood
until the graphics he did that Graphics
were Midway and making those little
Japanese planes blow up and stuff that's
what he did yeah
um but uh
yeah he says like kind of like special
effects right like digital effects and
stuff like that yeah that's what he did
then he became a full-time
protester he's an activist yeah that's
all he does
well because I mean he lives like right
there around like where Scientology is
so you know what I mean well he was
doing Scientology because it was there
and it was available he was making money
on it but now he's making money on other
stuff too so he he'll he'll do any kind
of last I heard from him he he'll do any
kind of activism yeah
well he's kind of more like people know
who he is because he had like a large
following like on YouTube so yeah
but you know there's that gateway to
inner earth maybe I mean it might as
well be like the [ __ ] like the [ __ ] they
come up with like the names they come up
with stuff they always want it to sound
well like ooh like high-tech and [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that like L Ron would come up
with Scientology is no joke that that
church is huge physically I mean it's
got properties everywhere and um
it has more properties than members I
think because they're probably they have
to be a church
so they so they can't hoard money they
got to keep spending money every time
they raise money they gotta spend it
and they're [ __ ] crazy they're kind
of like
they're kind of paramilitary
and they kind of believe in [ __ ]
mythical Concepts that that the military
believes in like what I was in that that
you can constantly improve exponentially
forever
you know which that is so every day they
do kind of like self-criticism things
where they have to fill out a report
card and rat on themselves of whether or
not their numbers increased or decreased
for the day
so they constantly have to be growing
the churches constantly has to be
growing so they can convince themselves
that they're taking over the world
they don't call it taking over the world
they call it clearing the planet
that sounds nicer yeah they're gonna
clear the planet at 60 000 a person yeah
okay I'd like to see that bro it's not
gonna happen all right and um
just ridiculous you know so
they it forces them to do things like
raise money and buy properties so it's
kind of like a
it's kind of like a virus like a
computer virus it just keeps doing the
same thing over and over again so they
have all these [ __ ] empty pristine
looking properties everywhere and they
give them all these fantastic names but
they don't really have a need for them
they'll just put some Scientology books
up on the window and put a bunch of Down
video screens in it and he'll have one
person in there 24 hours a day just
watch it watching to try to trying to
spread Scientology nobody ever damn
walks in the door because why would you
why would you right
why would anyone locked yeah that's
probably like you know
honestly it sounds like hey if they're
gonna pay you [ __ ] I'll go sit in a
bookstore for however many hours a day
they're not done and nobody comes in I
know I know they're not paying them
that's the thing I think they're mostly
sea org people or what or something else
called staff they don't pay them
they're just kind of like slaves they
feed them
they kind of give them a place to sleep
but that's about it and they don't get
much sleep they keep them awake
constantly
because it's kind of like basic training
yeah and um keeping people from sleeping
keeps them malleable you can you can
control them easier or break them a bad
habits that's another thing it can do
so that's why the military does it
they're also trying to weak out weed out
the week people that can't be instructed
that kind of stuff
Ben says some of their Associated
organizations are funny I always used to
get pamphlets from the citizens
Commission on human rights which is an
anti-psychiatry Lobby group yeah they
also run um narcanon I don't know if you
guys know that
um they have and they have some offshoot
ones too because when I used to work at
a print shop uh over in Longwood
every now and then like there'd be some
weird church that would come in and like
want some pamphlets or Flyers like print
it out and they always would have some
kind of like weird sounding name but
then like some of the language and stuff
on there I'm like that's a Scientology
front group because as soon as like you
know the um the South Park episode came
out or as soon as Leah Remini came out
and like started making her show and as
soon as everybody realized what a what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] show it was then they
started pulling all these little groups
like these little offshoot groups and
there's groups too of like people that
left Scientology but still believe in it
so they're kind of like starting their
own [ __ ] too that's Marty Rathbun Marty
Rathbun yeah his group he had a little
bit to do with this Lisa McPherson used
to yeah Marty left the church but he's
still a Scientologist he teaches
Scientology for free but they're after
him sending the squirrel Busters after
him and [ __ ] squirreling the tech is
what that's called yeah in other words
undercutting their profit margins well
yeah that's exactly that's why they're
bad yeah mad at that they don't want to
they don't want people teaching
Scientology like that but the
information is so [ __ ] valuable Jesus
Christ yeah it's the biggest bunch of
[ __ ] you've ever heard in your life
well I don't know about that that's
that's a that's a pretty bold statement
because I've heard a lot about stuff
I've heard a lot of [ __ ] in my life
but um you know what I mean it's up
there though it's up there it's up there
uh yeah murder Hornet said it's a snitch
culture yeah exactly yeah um yeah and
Ben's talking about the free personality
tests on the street corners yeah yeah
that's one of their big things
um
a very weird mixture of like corporatism
and military military corporatism and
Soviet communism they use a lot of the
same tactics as like the KGB and my
control type [ __ ]
yeah because they were from the Cold War
that era yeah and L Ron Hubbard was a a
naval commander and he commanded a
mind-sweeping ship some kind of mind
sweep and Destroyer or something
and uh he was just a military guy and in
that era it's still kind of like that
Military Officers are very corporate
they like how things are done on a
Corporate Way
and he was combining like
he was making a corporate religion for
America it was very very American
very corporate but it had infused in it
a lot of damn Soviet mind weapons and
mind control type devices like something
that not even Soviet I might want to say
it's like maoist probably like something
that Mao is China would use on you you
know re-education type techniques
American Military 100 said keeping
people sleep deprived was a tactic used
by Jim Jones also yeah a lot of Cults do
[ __ ] like that yeah because yeah for
that very reason after you haven't had
sleep for a couple days You're Gonna
things are gonna start getting a little
hazy around the edges uh you know that's
how that goes
and Ben says Millennium did a great
Parody episode of them with the
selfieologists and the Mystery
electrocution death of an apostate
ex-member that's like pretty funny
actually actually that's a good that
that that's a good name for himself
theologists because or selfie yeah
selfie because to really make it to
really be susceptible to Scientology you
have to really be into yourself
you have to be constantly worried about
yourself and your own
progress and you also have to like and
you also have to kind of like think that
one somebody outside who doesn't know
you can tell you how to like fix your
[ __ ] yeah and two you have to really
really like hierarchy and structure and
corporate [ __ ] and I don't like any
of those things which is why it never
appealed to me and you also have to have
a real strong desire to be approved of
you you have to really care about what
other people think of you so you have to
be kind of conformist to begin with
corporate conformist kind of superficial
um
trying to fit in and you always have to
uh you have to think real highly of
yourself
in other words
you'll hear you'll hear this theme over
and over again with Scientology there's
something wrong with the world and it's
our responsibility to save the world and
to help people
that's an arrogant [ __ ] claim you
know it is that you're good enough and
that you are squared away enough and
strong enough
to fix the [ __ ] world
that's [ __ ]
and these people are ate the [ __ ] up
when you see them I'll run into them
all right
they think they're awesome yeah they
think you know they have a wizard
complex
all right and I'm like well I'm very
respectfully disagreeing yeah that
you're awesome
from what I've seen they tend to be
mediocre
yeah
there's nothing to them
yeah they think there's something to
them but and I mean the very fact that
they would be lured into something like
that in the first place that already
makes me look a scant sit there like
[ __ ] I mean it's you know it's a
different story if you were raised in
the [ __ ] and that's like all you know
like you were a kid
um you know then you get a pass but
other than that uh if you as an adult
like kind of got
sucked into this I just I don't know
like what what about it would appeal to
you like I feel like maybe back in the
old days when you didn't really know
when they didn't really know
but nowadays there's like no excuse
evidently David miscavige and Tom Cruise
just treat them all like [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] and they probably are
yeah they probably are dumb [ __ ] well I
mean we've talked about this before but
miscavaged and Cruz they just seem like
the most arrogant [ __ ] [ __ ] ever
yeah you know what I mean it'd be like
heaven for them
[ __ ] run around tell me what to do
yeah like they're Admirals that's what I
mean they are like like it is like
paramilitary they run around like
they're because honestly one of the
things of of the many personality traits
that I can't stand in a person
um I can't stand people that are really
like um as the British would say up
themselves I can't stand people that
think that they're like better than
everybody and are like arrogant and
think they have some kind of like
privilege like they can tell you what to
do because they're better or smarter or
something I'm like [ __ ] off well they
better be able to deliver
if you could do that you better be able
to deliver even that even then I'm like
I still don't want your dumbass telling
me what to do knock it off you know what
I mean it's like I don't know I don't
know I don't get it and I don't get like
where I don't get why they think they're
so much cooler and that's what makes me
laugh like every time Tom Cruise like
says all that [ __ ] about because he's a
Scientologist so he's the only one that
can do this that the other thing I'm
like get the [ __ ] out of here that
[ __ ] yeah you're talking about
talking about that thing where he's
talking about the the uh
car wrecks and the ambulances and that
you jump out and you're the only person
that can help because you're sanitized
he he's he's telling the party line they
got him up there look you gotta fire up
the church man [ __ ] tell them what
they want to hear so I think he was
doing his job really you know
sounds ridiculous to us but
scientologists love that [ __ ] that's the
kind of [ __ ] they want to hear
we're the best ever yeah yeah it was a
Rara speech I'm like no
he doesn't [ __ ] believe that I hope
not because if he did he'd have some
problems he knows who those signs are
who the [ __ ] would act if you actually
really did believe that you probably
need some mental help I'm a
scientologists are a real Scientologist
in general they're just mediocre you
know they're not that's what I mean not
Superman yeah but that's the thing I
kind of feel like these would feel like
they should be Superman yeah it's like
so they can like talk themselves into
like they're the most they're more
awesome than everybody else and I'm just
like just kidding they have their own
little ways of talking and doing things
and if you don't do it their way then
you're you're then you're you're a
[ __ ] sub-human that's the way they
think pretty much yeah they're like oh
well you know what you're talking about
because you don't know this Tech and you
don't know this and that and we're the
only ones that know anything yeah and
that's not what happened what happened
was is that L Ron Hubbard was hanging
out with a bunch of guys one of them was
uh you know Anton LaVey and they were
they just got on the they got on the
damn uh Aleister Crowley make a
[ __ ] a wizard [ __ ] technique
where if you promise to make a
[ __ ] wizard you can get money
out of him leveling him up well pay me
some more money and I'll bring it to the
next level next thing you know you'll be
raising the dead did all kinds of that
that's that's all they're doing they
call it [ __ ] going up the bridge
and the thing about it it's almost kind
of like foolproof because if the person
calls you out on your [ __ ] like hey
I couldn't like bring a person back from
the den they're like well you're just
not good you're not good enough you're
just not good enough that's your fault
we told you how to do it right you're
just not doing it right I mean pretty
much like all religions pull that
[ __ ] yeah but then they go we gotta
send you back to [ __ ] square one okay
we're gonna take all your ranks away
yeah pay for those yeah but you didn't
learn it right you got to go back to
[ __ ] OT you gotta go back to a ot4
we're gonna start you over again you're
actually an ot4 yeah and see they pay a
[ __ ] ton of money to go up to those OT
levels most of them don't even go up
them
don't have the money to pay for it it
just gets stuck in the dam
sea org which is like the sea
organization is kind of like their
version of the fake Navy it's like the
the it's their clergy but it's run like
a paramilitary type organization they
don't have any weapons
to speak of
they better not a wall be in trouble
mopping floors setting up books and [ __ ]
and [ __ ]
building [ __ ] you know renovating the
inside of [ __ ] buildings and stupid
[ __ ] like that granther says Battlefield
Earth with John Travolta and Barry
Pepper is often lumped in with Ishtar
and Howard the Duck as the worst movies
ever made when will there be a 13
o'clock review we probably should
although honestly I don't I have never
been able to sit through the whole
entire thing yeah it's bad but I liked
it I thought it was [ __ ] hilarious
although I'll get a bat for Howard the
Duck I actually really like her the duck
but not for battlefielder that movie
just made me want to like fall asleep I
don't know what it was it's just kind of
like I liked Battlefield Earth because I
understood Battlefield Earth
the [ __ ] the guy who's supposed to be
the hero in Battlefield Earth is a
spitting image it's the dead ringer for
David miscavage himself so you know that
they cast this dude to actually be David
miscavige savior savior of the world
against the aliens yeah Miss cabbage
probably got a [ __ ] lower than
watching that [ __ ] yeah and then you had
hey it's me John Travolta running around
and big ass [ __ ] shoes and
they shot him in a way and they think
they might have had like some extensions
on their feet to make them like another
eight or eight or nine inches taller
and it just it was funny man all I
remember from that movie was that it was
like greenish blue the whole time and
everything was shot in Dutch angles yeah
I think it was yeah so it's kind of like
a cartoon movie after that I was just
well it wasn't even as fun as that
implies I was just like sitting there
going
I don't even care what's going on I'm
like
I don't know I just found it really
really boring it wasn't even really
entertaining enough to like keep it
wasn't bad it was bad but it wasn't like
bad in a way that would want to make me
keep watching so it's funny this is
supposed to be it's supposed to be
promoting Scientology but the alien the
Alien Invaders
the way they operated they were kind of
showing them as a bad example like you
know a Ultra greedy business people who
were totally into corporate [ __ ]
rules and regulations and how to get
leverage on people maybe to them that's
good though
I don't understand to who
to the scientologists no that is
something that's what I mean that is
science so you see that as a good but
they're but no they were portraying them
they portrayed them as the bad guys and
that they get but it's it's just more
double [ __ ] speak you know what I
mean the way the way the bad guys were
in that
movie is the way Scientology is the way
the good guys are in that movie that's
not the way Scientology is that's just
the way regular people are
so it's they use reverse psychology on
people either that or maybe
scientologists are so deluded that they
actually think that they're like the
good guys like that they are like the
good guys are portrayed in the movie
well the low-level people the public and
the people the the people that join that
church who you know they're not only in
there for you know a couple years maybe
or whatever yeah they think that but no
the uh if you look at miscavige and just
the ways L Ron Hubbard and just the way
that that [ __ ] was organized no it's
like the way the aliens were
that's all they do is worry about money
money and hierarchy getting leverage on
people and it's kind of got a corporate
structure to it that's Scientology yeah
Ben says I've heard the Battlefield
Earth books aren't that bad but I never
was inspired to read them yeah I'm just
kind of like one I'm not a real big
sci-fi person to begin with and honestly
they're you know probably millions of
other books I would probably rather be
reading rather than
because what would happen like if you
let's say for example that you bought
not that anyone would do this but that
you bought one of L Ron Hubbard
Scientology books like new where does
that money go does that still go to
Scientology or no yeah that's what I
thought yeah so if you're going to just
check it out of the library or something
yeah don't give them any money
Battlefield Earth is a great study of
confession through projection is what it
is
they're confessing scientologists
confessing to What It Is by projecting
its evils onto the alien characters the
evil alien characters a lot of people do
that
confession through projection
yeah that's that's very common yeah
yeah well it's weird it's really common
because
you'd think it would be really obvious
but I guess to people it's not obvious
that that's what they're doing no the
average person is 100 IQ that's dumb
half of them are dumber than that I mean
that's just the way it is people believe
what they're told George Carlin said
that yep it's true
um what's better than him huh why are
you going to credit him he's dead no I'm
just saying he's the one that said that
yeah it's true though
um what's up Dave he says hello to you
too I'm pooped and now we got gobble
gobble Time Yeah tomorrow's Thanksgiving
I'm trying to
anything except the Chinese food today
so hopefully because I enjoy all the
Thanksgiving food but I can't really eat
that much of it at one time and it makes
me mad uh greenspark said what are you
drinking it looks nice it's just like
vodka and lemonade right yeah lemonade
with [ __ ] in it yeah it's just vodka
lemonade but yeah so I don't know I I
probably would never be inspired to read
the Battlefield Earth books I can barely
sit through the movie I'm sure the books
are better they usually are but like I
said I've got millions of other things
I'd rather be reading I didn't think the
movie was that bad the special effects
weren't that good it just it's kind of a
hokey story it had but it did have some
good things about it you know what I
mean like it had the damn machine it
could the learning machine or the Rays
would go into your eyes you can interact
with it and you could see the little
alien is trying to teach you the teach
you the Cyclone language and it it
when it made contact when they put they
put the human in the in the book they
wanted to teach him how to speak cyclo
which is that was like the language that
the aliens used
and [ __ ] particles and Rays went into
his eyes and he could see and it started
to communicate with him and they had a a
language they called it he called
himself a language slave and he goes
excuse me I I do not mean to protect do
not mean to pretend to have the
authority to teach you the language of
cyclo but I am just a lowly language
slave and I have been you know
instructed to to to to to have you know
to teach you this with you know he's
apologizing
for teaching you something because he
thinks you're a cyclope and the Cyclones
had the Cyclones had taken over his
planet and [ __ ] and he teaches uh
teaches the human guy how to speak cyclo
and then he could understand it and they
wanted him in the
[Music]
the
cyclo dude who is being played by um
uh what's his [ __ ] name I just said
just said his name um Captain Greece
Travolta yeah John Travolta uh he's
going behind the company's back gonna
try to mine all this gold because he
wants to buy his way out of that off of
that planet because he's stuck there on
duty there he wants to get out of there
he needs a big old bribe if I remember
correctly of all these gold bars and he
has to be able to talk to this human
slave that they had all these human
slaves they were kind of went to this
barbaric level they were kind of like
cavemen when because they had destroyed
[ __ ]
human civilization you know centuries
before
and uh
once he learned how to speak cyclo he
also learned a bunch of other stuff and
uh led a revolt and got rid of the
aliens
it's a pretty good story just that
there's certain aspects of it that
weren't plausible yeah but although
you're just describing it made my eyes
glaze over
that's the way it's the way
scientologists think though I know well
I know I used to know a lot of them so
yeah I know how they think if you want
to use that word yeah uh granther said
religious movies are always low value
entertainment yeah for whatever reason
uh examples include fireproof with Kirk
Cameron yeah and father stew with Marky
Mark proof wasn't any good fireproof um
I never sat through the whole movie but
I did
um I did watch the god awful movies
episode about it or listen to the
podcast about it and they'll do as we
saw that's what it was like we listen
and they go through like minute by
minute so a lot of times their podcast
is like significantly longer than the
actual movie that they're talking about
because they talk about like every
single thing and just like make jokes
about it the whole time but that was
there's a lot of like Kurt camera ones
there's another one called saving
Christmas which really sounds like a
[ __ ] hoot I don't it's like I don't
I just like I said there's so many good
movies out there it's like they sound
funny but
I want to I want to listen to somebody
like making fun of them then I'll engage
with that but I'm not gonna like sit
there and watch it myself and like make
up my own jokes I'm too lazy for that I
want somebody else to make up shows
about it for me that's the only reason
that's the only way that I'm actually
gonna watch is or like listen to it is
so it has to be like God awful movies or
Nick deramio on YouTube or somebody like
that because he does religious movies
sometimes too so it just has to be
somebody making fun of it and then I'll
watch it I'm not gonna sit the right
place Battlefield Earth probably could
have been successful but the budget
would have been bigger the writing would
have been better
and I don't think you could tell that
story in one movie it would have been
better if it was like a three movies
yeah
and I don't know if you can keep
people's attention that long
for that
because the scope of Battlefield Earth
is like about the size of Dune if I
remember correctly it's a bunch of books
yeah I thought it wasn't just one I
thought it was like a whole series like
the whole extended kind of universe
type of [ __ ] and it's like when did even
he write that because I kind of feel
like it was 50s what 50s and 60s
yeah were the books actually
specifically now I can't even remember
the books actually specifically written
in order to plug Scientology yeah or did
he just like retroactively like retrofit
the story like into the Scientology
Mythos it had Scientology values to it
or so-called values or so-called
Scientology values
that's the way Scientology Scientology
didn't really have those values they
just claimed to have those values the
main thing from Battlefield Earth was
kind of like anti-corporate greed
science the Church of Scientology is not
really any not not really anybody that
has should be lecturing anybody on
corporate greed I mean that's what right
I mean Jesus
they're one of the last people that
should have anything to say about you
have anything to say about that that's
what that is
but like I said it's confession through
projection
pretty much yeah Ben says Scientology
was to push the books originally I think
yeah see that makes more sense to me
that makes more sense because I thought
that the books were older like predated
the founding of the religion because you
know what I mean I hate to call it that
but I don't know cult I guess we'll just
call it cult because that's what it is
it didn't become a religion until until
after they started off outside
and then they realized that it didn't it
didn't it wasn't a tax shelter
so they had to pay taxes so they had to
in L Ron elbrom was still alive he's
like well we have to convert this into a
into a religious Faith so they started
putting crosses on things and calling it
a religion and say this is a and then
they uh got tax exempt status accepted
yeah so
it was just it was supposed to be a it
started off as Dianetics which was a
kind of a teaser way of selling you a
bunch of self-help books and then they
wouldn't the self-help books weren't
going to be enough the self-help books
were going to tell you to go to a
Scientology organization and they would
help you like a school like a training
school
probably got that [ __ ] from Dune with
the Benny Jesuit and all those [ __ ]
the chome guilds and all that and the
[ __ ] yeah because that kind of stuff
is in
Dune private schools to teach you mental
powers
wouldn't surprise me if you got her mad
yeah he probably did because he because
he like I said Battlefield Earth
Battlefield Earth was kind of like
and I think he wrote those it's kind of
like Dune and I think it was written
over a long period of time I know there
was a [ __ ] ton of books
so I'm sure some of that stuff
overlapped with fake Hubert from some of
his time somebody might be able to do
the do the numbers I'm just surmising
y'all run Hubbard red science red
science fiction he liked it well yeah
that's how he's made his money before he
started a religion science fiction book
so he's probably talking about the Benny
Jesuit
probably what Dynex was
Richard Brown said Battlefield Earth was
directed by one of the effects
technicians on alien so you know no
slouch I guess slasher Fred said there
was a Kirk Cameron movie called like
father like son that was like a like
Father and Son okay that was like a
masculine version of Freaky Friday oh
like where they switched bodies okay I
don't want to see that one either Parker
Cameron like I feel like what did he was
he always crazy or because he was um
like normal in the 80s right he was on
that sitcom what the [ __ ] was the name
of that sitcom
I can't remember the name of the sitcom
but he was on one of the sitcoms and he
was like really really famous and then
it just seemed like he kind of dropped
out of sight for a few years and then he
came back and he was like a wing nut so
I don't know how that happened then like
he was in all these like weird ass
hanging out with creationists and making
all these [ __ ] crazy ass movies and
[ __ ] Growing Pains thank you that's what
it was called I couldn't remember the
name of that [ __ ] show to save my
life
it's not your friend saying cyclos
sounds like the bad guys from Battle
strugglected those were they were the
cylons
Asylum well still that is pretty close
yeah Cylon cyclo yeah the cyclos I think
they're supposed to be kind of like the
psychos you know yeah psychos but
they're subtle yeah cyclos I think you
know what what L Ron is talking about
he's talking about [ __ ] um SPS he's
talking about suppressive persons that's
bad people
yeah yeah suppress a person
oh Grandpa's talking about Kirk Cameron
oh he married an Evangelical Christian
and made him and who made him convert oh
okay well that explains it because yeah
I was saying like back in the 80s when
he was like a teenager in his 20s and he
was on growing pains he seemed like a
normal enough dude
um but then like he came out later I'm
like man what the [ __ ] happened to him
I think one of the similar kind of thing
happened to uh what's her face from uh
Clarissa Explains It All what's her name
Melissa Joan Hart she's in a bunch of
those religious movies too so it was
like Kevin Sorbo that used to be on uh
Hercules yeah he'll do a religious movie
yeah that's all he could do now yeah so
there's like a whole like little there's
a whole little ghetto of like actors
that'll do that because a lot of them
they're like they believe that stuff so
that's why they're like in those movies
yeah but yeah Sorbo is in all those
[ __ ] God's Not Dead movies yeah which
were again which I've never sat through
the whole thing but like I watched made
a living breakdowns well I don't know I
don't know maybe I think he made a
living at him
yeah Zach says like how Tom Cruise
married his first wife who got him into
Scientology yes well what's all these
wives like trying to [ __ ]
that's the easiest way to get a dude
into a cult is to send women at him be
like hey wouldn't this cult be a good
idea why don't you drink this poison
cooling flirty fishing yeah flirty
fishing well that's that one cult that
we talked about a long time but never
called it yeah which you might as well
call it all that because that's what it
is yeah trying to tricks is another word
for it that's what regular people would
call it yeah getting money for the
church by putting out
pretty much yeah yeah that's something
when you have a Christian cult and you
just turn all the women into into
hookers for you hookers for Christ
and then they're doing [ __ ] with
Children what was the name of that one
[ __ ] chill children of God we never
isn't it wait was it children of God or
was it something I know I get them
confused he wasn't a God I think it
might have been yeah yeah we did a show
a long time ago about that yeah
mandatory pedoism and [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] manther says my mom made my
dad convert after a few months of dating
oh grandfather would not be here had he
said no
I don't know like I said I guess it's
hard for me to like um really relieve
because I wasn't raised religious it
wasn't really something that we talked
about
um you know in my family so it's just
kind of like
I just I don't know I just thought it
was like really weird when I heard about
that uh blue horseshoe said Xeno in the
wall of fire sure yeah yeah it was Mo
Berg and the children of God okay so you
got it right yeah children of God yeah
yeah
there we go yeah all these all these
shows yeah we did we did a show on him
yeah we did I think it was um I think we
did a show with children of God and
maybe one other cult like it was a two
cult it was a two it's a two-pronged
cult attack is what it was uh if I
remember correctly
yeah no no freakazoids yeah they are
yeah
um
let's see slasher friend said speaking
of Growing Pains the series once had a
short-lived series called just the 10 of
us oh yeah I remember that I remember
that that had the actresses who were in
The Nightmare on Elm Street Series yeah
I remember that too
yeah it's you know it's not it's not fun
but like so like I said anytime you're
trying to make a movie that's trying to
push a particular religious agenda it
usually is not good and we've talked
about this before like there are movies
that could be said to be religious like
for example this is the example I always
use like the Exorcist is very clearly
like a Catholic movie because it's it
posits that Catholicism is correct and
they could drive out the demons and they
were the heroes and stuff like that but
it's not trying to like necessarily push
that
they're not trying to convert people to
Catholicism it's just like showing you a
story where a certain thing happens you
know what I mean so if you guys don't
know what Scientology is
put it in a nutshell
there's a bunch of there's a it has a
bunch of different
I guess you could say a bunch of
different aspects to it in terms of
business aspect what it is
it's
a bunch of it's a series of self-help
books
that they try to sell
and this then the self-help books
encourage you to go to organizations and
get direct
Scientology training to help you with
your problems now you're going to find
out you got problems you never even
thought of since as soon as Scientology
gets a hold of you okay
um
this self-help program ended up being
accepted as a religion under U.S law so
it became
tax exempt but to get that tax exempt
status there's a bunch of weird [ __ ]
that they have to do they can't hoard
money they they have to like constantly
prosthetolize their prostatize what do
you call it uh there's a bunch of stuff
that they have to do to prove to to the
federal government that they're a
religion
so it makes Scientology do weird things
like endlessly buy property
property that they don't need because
they can't have money building up in the
bank
once it became a religion
the religion okay the religion was
basically based on stuff L Ron Hubbard
had been writing he wrote a lot of [ __ ]
a lot a lot of different stuff
on on each subject he talked about in
these books
they're like he'll have a whole he had a
whole book just based on like radiation
[Laughter]
and he got he had that all figured yeah
yeah it's spoiler alert yeah and you
might need to know about radiation okay
and so they have to sell you this book
okay
L Ron Hubbard was uh uh a generalist he
was not a a [ __ ] scientist
he did not specialize in any one thing
he could spin a yard
he was a bullshitter he was a
bullshitter yeah all right and there and
he was very American and according to
people that grew up around him and you
know knew him when he was alive he was a
very charismatic guy people liked him
and uh he was actually pretty good to
the cult members he didn't abuse anybody
there wasn't any sexual abuse or
anything which is really unusual for a
lot of cult leaders because he had these
little teenage girls follow him around
everywhere in these little short shorts
his little Messengers on the free winds
you know on the boats and he wasn't
messing with any of these women so
it's not where that's not where L Ron
Hubbard's thing was hell runs the
Hubbard's thing was to be important and
to be the center of attention and to
tell everybody tell stories and
entertain the cult and
build an Empire so I gotta had it to L
Ron Hubbard he as far as cult leaders go
he wasn't an abusive one
well much no no we'll we'll get into get
into it something now there were people
in the cult that were like that that
kind of did a lot of weird [ __ ] he
wasn't real great with his family he
wasn't a good family man
um he had he'd kind of discard one
family and pick up another one
but you know he did
which all that's just kind of explained
in his belief systems that even children
are adults there's all kinds of stuff
that is in Scientology
um
what the religion is
is this
trying to explain it in the terminology
that a non-scientologist could
relate to it is a UFO possession it's a
demonic
alien UFO possession cope
that's what it's about
aliens were here a long time ago and
they imprisoned a bunch of evil demons
uh into volcanoes and try to destroy
them by dropping atomic bombs on them
this is long before humans lived here
and those alien Souls were set free they
weren't destroyed and then when humans
arrived these these alien demons could
attach to you and they were called
engrams if I remember correctly
uh or I think they're called engrams
wait where do the thetans come in
oh yeah but I think the thetans caused
engrams I don't remember exactly what it
was so these alien Souls could attach to
you and that's why you're an alcoholic
and that's why you pick your nose or
whatever you know oh well that explains
the lies
that's why you're gay that's why uh you
can't [ __ ] take care of your money
it's why you can't keep it in your pants
it's why you're a hoe or a garden tool
that's why yeah I'm gonna start being
polite just called a garden yeah
[Laughter]
that's why okay so what you do is is
once you've identified that these alien
evil demons are attached to you and
slightly possessing you making you do
all this bad stuff
you're gonna have to go through auditing
is one of the things and auditing is
where you get on a lie detector A
Primitive lie detector and they ask you
a bunch of questions and they can
evidently tell whether or not you're
lying or not and then you have to
confess and all that shit's written down
and recorded
for later use okay because if you ever
leave the church betray them then they
got all the dirt on you
all of what you what you did all your
sins and [ __ ] now use that against you
so it's an alien
possession demonic possession cult
that performs exorcisms demonic
exorcisms on a lie detector test
and they do this during confession
and your confessions are all recorded
okay
and they're all analyzed by experts okay
that they have
and these experts try to figure out what
these experts what training you should
have next to push you down the correct
path
now as you go you're gonna have to level
up you're gonna you know if you have the
money and you can't just level up
because you're good you got to pay for
this Trinity to level your ass up until
you're a [ __ ] wizard basically and as
you level up you get more and more
Force powers like like out of Star Wars
eventually it gets to a point where you
have control over space and time
where you can back time up and redo
something say
like let's say for instance and it
that's later on that's like ot7 or eight
or something or six I don't remember how
high that how that how high up you have
to be before you can reverse time
but what they'll tell you is this we've
been driving this car all day you know
you could have died driving this car but
you stopped it backed it up fixed the
problem and went through it again and
you didn't die and you never knew so
you're secretly protecting yourself and
reversing time all the time that's so
[ __ ] powerful that's how powerful you
are and then so I stubbed my toe though
the other day why not [ __ ] back it up
yeah sw2 ain't [ __ ] you broke your arm
three weeks ago oh go but you didn't
know because you stopped time backed it
up and went through it again and your
arm didn't break and you didn't remember
it because you know you erased to that
timeline that's how they that's how they
justify this [ __ ] and you you might have
to spend several hundred thousand
dollars to get to that probably like in
a half a million this they have it so
it's a lot of money it's a lot of money
you got a lot of Rich nerds out there
that'll give up a lot of money to get
this [ __ ] yeah I kind of feel like and
probably they have this thing because
I'm gonna I want to get into this a
little bit too because this is kind of
this is a very American uh mindset but
they probably have a thing where it's
like if you like for example you passed
all the tests or whatever delayed to go
to the next like [ __ ] OT level or
whatever the [ __ ] but you didn't have
the money to do that and then they would
turn that they'd flip that around on you
and say well obviously you didn't do it
all right because if you had then you
would have enough money you'd be ready
to go up to the next like you would be
rich already and like I said that's a
very that's a peculiarly American
mindset that it's like it ties in how
much money you have with like your moral
fiber yeah it's always been that way
it's I know and it's like it's very very
weird that must be like some kind of
like
um I don't know where that comes from
because that seems to be like American
seems to be like the only people that
think like that that's kind of a can-do
thing there's opportunities we're pretty
good here in the in America so there was
always a way to make money
and if you weren't making money you
weren't making much money as that guy
over there it's because you're not doing
the doing what he's doing if you were
doing what he was doing then you'd have
that money
um the thing is is that Christianity
played into that and I think it had a
lot to do with like Lutheranism and
other kinds of yeah yeah I think that's
where I'm hard work always resulted in
good income which that is not the case
it's not always the case but a lot of
sometimes it's true I mean it helps but
um right you know but sometimes you just
work hard and then you're still poor and
you die yeah
if you want to make a lot of money
you're not working hard or usually
working smarter and if you actually
investigate how these guys in their 30s
or 40s are making millions of dollars by
the time they're 40. they're working in
a team and it's other guys who are right
on top of Cutting Edge information and
they see money as a stream and they know
well this guy's doing this and that and
when that happens money will [ __ ]
start flowing this way if we borrow a
bunch of money like a couple million
dollars we'll set up this [ __ ] thing
we'll catch some of that money and we'll
triple our profits and [ __ ] you know
and we'll all divide it back up so
they're working as a team
and they're working on very Cutting Edge
information things that the average
person wouldn't even know was happening
you know that's how you really make
money it's kind of like in insider
trading or well largely I mean largely
you kind of already have to have money
to have money and then you have to have
you have to have accurate up-to-date
information you don't you're kind of
[ __ ] you have to have accurate
up-to-date daily information about what
the richest [ __ ] in the world
are doing right now if you know if you
know what they're doing then you can
plan
and then they're doing stuff on the
stock market
because they know how it's going to
affect that
gramper says uh Katie Holmes Nicole
Kidman Penelope Cruz have said the same
things about Tom Cruise and Scientology
it just all got to be too much I could
see that I mean [ __ ] I was only around
you know some of them like you know over
the course of a work day over like eight
or nine months and I started feeling
like I wanted to jump off a [ __ ]
building just dealing with them for that
small amount of time so I can't imagine
being married to somebody like that and
like being around them all the time [ __ ]
that noise no thank you now according to
Scientology the greatest Scientologist
of all times was that Ron Hubbard
they call him the source he was the
source of all their knowledge the source
of all the Bulls the source of all the
Bulls
all of his all of his works are written
down on these stainless steel tablets
and they're inside these damn big
[ __ ] bomb-proof [ __ ] cases and
they're stored in an underground
facility out in the middle of the desert
has a big concrete walls around it and
[ __ ] machine guns and [ __ ] out in the
middle of the goddamn desert to save L
Ron Hubbard's writings in case of atomic
Armageddon they've had guys stationed
out there that have killed themselves
because there's just nothing out there
depression gets them basically like
being in prison Maximum Security Prison
but they have these secret [ __ ] bases
underground bases
to hide steel tablets are they even I
thought they were like platinum or some
[ __ ] no that's not what it was it was
stainless steel with uh I think it might
have had some kind of coating on it and
they were [ __ ] putting put them into
a carbon fiber
carbon fiber cases and stuff it was a
real high-tech [ __ ] but it was I don't
think it was Platinum
um meanwhile people are starving to
death in the world and they're putting
all this [ __ ] on [ __ ] stainless
steel tablets and burying them in a
desert bunker yeah yeah [ __ ] off with
that well it makes me so mad they have
to because they would did that kind it
sounds ridiculous
but uh it's because they have to do
things that churches do they can't hoard
money so they have to build things like
that
or I have an idea send me some yeah you
can't you or they would or they wouldn't
be a religion basically I might actually
do some good with it instead of all the
[ __ ] you guys are doing send me a
couple so L Ron Hubbard was the source
he was the greatest Scientologist of all
times and uh he died
which that kind of goes against what
sometimes why he wasn't supposed to die
no no he dropped it he dropped his body
he reworded that whoops he just dropped
his body he went into another dimension
like a banana to further work his work
but he's coming back he's coming back
with ot10 right or nine
oh [ __ ] because he's died when he was
trying to write the next level
and uh they they some of them kind of
had theorized or Justified well he had
to drop his body to go into the other
dimension to get the knowledge that he
needed in order to complete I think it
was ot9 or or whatever
once he came back so
on all these bases there's always a
house there big [ __ ] mansion and
that's one of elron Hubbard's mansions
and it's got everything laid out his
packs of cigarettes I think you Cool
cigarettes yeah that's so cool what
happens if cool goes out of business
anyway they got Cool cigarettes way down
for him his Scientology is probably
single-handed
it probably would buy the cool yeah that
might be why they're still because do
you know anybody that smokes those I
don't know
at the uh they smell cool out in the
hood
but he smoked them so they got a pack of
cigarettes out for him his his uh uh
uniform and his shoes are out and his
beds made and every day they make sure
all in all these every one of these
bases has an L Ron Hubbard house or most
of the good bases has a house that they
gotta [ __ ] that they're keeping it
for when he comes back
and they totally believe he's gonna come
back
enter Tom Ross
show up
I keep telling him that you should I was
like you're a good bullshitter too you
can tell [ __ ] you could totally do that
you could totally do that yeah I just
got to do more characters to well you
say
[Laughter]
I'm back now I have no everything about
ot10 and we're gonna
we're gonna write ot10 all right
I've got it all here just whatever pull
everything pull anything out of here
where's my pack of cool thank you
right
you could totally do it that's right
well you can't now because you just said
it live on on YouTube but you know what
I mean I'll Channel him yeah there you
go yeah they'll just call me the host
and then whenever they need to speak to
you I'll call him forth
yeah so you can be your regular self
like yeah yeah
they need to that they need to talk to
Hubbard I'll [ __ ]
[Laughter]
pop his ass out here how you doing yeah
what you do you know
you should what you should like I'm
bossing [ __ ] Tom Cruise around and
[ __ ] oh my God that would be [ __ ]
epic get your ass up there on that mask
right
pull it tighter pull it tighter please
[ __ ] it dude please [ __ ] do it that
would be like so funny that would be
like the best [ __ ] troll ever come
here and it would actually be a troll
for good yeah yeah you know what I mean
you're riding that motorcycle too
[ __ ] fast
[Laughter]
you're gonna break your [ __ ] ass
ah we spent too much money on you Tom
I got Tom Cruise saying yes sir and [ __ ]
to me yeah we're a [ __ ] helmet
Tim Greenglass says the miserable dwarf
that runs scamatology today is far worse
than fat ass Elroy blubbered yeah yeah
that's true yeah yeah uh miscavige is um
he's mean yeah he's a terrible person
excuse me according to everybody well
it's not personal experience that ever
met the man
it might be cool to be if I meet him
because he I'm short too and we're we're
in a mafia there is a short guy Mafia we
treat each other well okay so you know
oh come on yeah again me and Tom Cruise
and David miscaviors all these short
[ __ ]
making fun of tall people
[Laughter]
smoking a joint
be [ __ ] funny but uh yeah
he's
uh according to what okay the
according to everything I've ever put
together about Miss cabbage he's
protecting
protecting the church first of all
you're logging the tag dog
if you come at the church he just wants
to destroy it doesn't even matter who
you are he went after his own dad okay
um that's the first thing
that's his duty you know he's chairman
of the board so he's committed
he cannot stand incompetence
which is going to be a big [ __ ]
problem in Scientology
because those [ __ ] are incompetent
thank you David June what do you say is
that broke [ __ ] paying broke [ __ ]
on Thanksgiving yeah the day
Thanksgiving
hahaha so
yeah he doesn't like he doesn't like
[ __ ]
um incompetence and he's surrounded by
incompetence which would make him
[ __ ] mad all the time
uh he
I'm he doesn't know that much about
scientology evidently he doesn't have a
lot of songs he doesn't have to he means
to be honest he doesn't seem to be very
interested in Scientology he's more
interested in making sure that the
organization continues
yeah seriously
um pokey's uh providing her two cents
there
I think uh
what was it gonna say more about him
he's
not like he can leave you know what I
mean and do something else anything he
did would be a big step down he grew up
in that cult that's all he knows well
and everybody knows who his ass is yeah
he doesn't have any education outside
that cult
um he's a ruthless manager of it
he's basically in military terminology
of [ __ ] lifer and he's a lifer that's
you know and if you knew what lifers are
like if you're ever in the Army it's
just a lifer
um they're they're totally part of a
system they're part of that machine
he's probably no fun
you know
well you can tell that just by looking
at his angry little face yeah and
getting him out of that system his me he
was he's meaningless outside that system
so he has to stay in there you can't go
come on man let's get the [ __ ] out of
here no man let's go come on let's go
get a drink man [ __ ] this [ __ ] let's be
normal yeah yeah
he wouldn't he wouldn't deal with that
he couldn't deal with that well no
because he likes being like the top dog
yeah you have to be in charge and if you
got him out of that system he he
couldn't like he's just a random thing
you're not equal to me you know what I
mean to be like a general being saying I
want to be a nobody you know because
he's equivalent to being a general
really if he was in an army which he
kind of is
um
I'm not a hater of these dudes I I
actually kind of I understand it be an
ex-military I understand how that could
happen to you
this is they've been doing this for a
long time and it's almost kind of like
an addiction
it's like an addict addicts understand
other addicts you know and it's kind of
like looking at a bunch of addicts
they're addicted to this [ __ ]
artificial system
they're not really they're not they
wouldn't have any importance without it
uh they're they have a bunch of
conflicting [ __ ] orders and
instructions on how to do things and it
kind of slowly I think drives them crazy
so and I think Tom Cruise is a little I
think he's a good dude but I think I
think Scientology kind of
put a lot of inner conflicts in into him
you know what I mean uh I think there's
reward and and uh punishment to it you
know like there's pros and cons to it
the pro is is that he can
have a lot of status inside the cup he
could feel good about his status
the con is is that other people don't
understand it they're going to attack
him
and uh he's not gonna be able to move
move around in normal society what well
he has to be outside of society which he
thinks is like in an elite core is what
he's gonna
but he's missing out on a lot you know
and knowing normal people really is
advantageous to you you can because
that's that's how you get grounded in in
what's real
you know what reality is these guys
really aren't in reality
yeah and that's the thing too it's just
like I mean they have to understand that
like the rest of the world just thinks
they're a bunch of weirdos yeah like
they don't take that seriously nobody
takes that seriously right and like they
might think they're all [ __ ] like
Elite and [ __ ] like that but nobody else
thinks that now they think they're just
weirdos but they look down their nose at
regular people like well you guys are
just [ __ ] they call them wogs yeah
which means [ __ ] which like I said in
the UK that's a racist term yeah but
they just called say well it just means
uh they had
they I think it stood for stood for
something it just meant
non-scientologists it's kind of like
calling somebody a coffer or a kefir or
calling somebody a down goyum or
something you know if I can
uh you're not one of us you're not one
of us yeah and we're [ __ ] special
right yeah let me go get some more eyes
yeah I'm I'm out too all mine melted
okay yeah
um I think it disappeared but
um somebody asked how old Lisa McPherson
was when she died she was 36 actually
36. Yeah Tim is pointing out uh wag is
yeah it's like the n-word in the UK yeah
I did I did know that actually
um because I lived over there for a
little while in the 90s but yeah so
that's why it's and I'm sure
they knew that I was I mean when they
came up with that term
they must have known that like what the
connotation of that word was it doesn't
mean that in the U.S but it totally does
like in the UK and that's pretty
commonly known I would have thought
um yeah Camp guy said they must fleece
their members like crazy get them to
sign over their real property stocks
real estate yeah I think they do
actually
um and I think in the case like in Lisa
McPherson's case I think she had well
she had her own bank account but then
like she had a Scientology bank account
that I guess they monitored that they
like put money for her in it but they
could take money out of it too
you know what I mean yeah
I you know
I don't think I don't think David
miscavis really believes in Scientology
no probably I don't think he does I
think Tom Cruise does
but I don't think he seems to yeah I
don't think I don't think this guy yeah
but I don't think Miss Catholic believes
in it no he's just like some [ __ ]
it's a business for him yeah he's just
running it like that and he's it's made
him Rich so that's all he worries about
I guess I don't know how much personal
money he has he probably has a good
amount of personal money but the
richness he actually lives in is that he
can move around freely through all those
damn bases like it's his personal
property
even though it's it's company property
basically
but it's Church property but he runs it
like it's a kingdom that's what I mean
Tom Cruise does too he could Tom Cruise
could go anywhere he wanted probably in
there and they'll do anything he asks
yeah like all he has to do is be like
hey can you pull up all this field of
flowers and like plant all new ones like
and then they'll do it yeah Tom could
pull in with one of his [ __ ] brand
new SUVs or something because I want the
whole interior torn out of there I want
a custom leather interior with this and
that I want all kinds of high-tech oh
yeah yeah we'll do that we'll do that
they'll [ __ ] he'll have him within a
few days so totally new interior and a
brand new vehicle
and you know with [ __ ] like high-tech
communication equipment so so in case
the [ __ ] world ends he's got a
satellite link up with [ __ ] Davis
cabbage he can get his daily [ __ ]
Scientology download
you see the stats you know seeing how
how much the planet has been cleared I
mean Jesus Christ
I would love to have some [ __ ] like that
but it the thing is this it's centered
around something I don't believe is it's
not real yeah obviously yeah they're
sitting around something that was real I
think it'd be even cooler it'd be real
cool
yeah it's decidedly not cool like the
way it is though
and honestly I can't imagine I don't
know I guess I've just never been the
kind of person that like rolls up
somewhere and is like hey do this for me
and that and the other thing like I
always feel like an [ __ ] doing it you
know what I mean it's like in the
military
it's just you it's normal
because there's different ranks and
hierarchies and well I get that but it's
just like I don't know I'm not this kind
of mission involved and you're being
told to do some things and you know hey
look this has to happen so you should go
everybody this is what we have to do get
this and you can do that you can keep
moving all right now but you know some
of that shit's kind of personal okay one
but you could read you could set it into
a different way you're gonna re-out fit
my vehicle because it's going to become
a command vehicle so I'll always be in
contact with you I want all new Terrier
in there make this [ __ ] hand crafted
okay it's gonna be [ __ ] badass so I
could talk to you all in style like you
deserve yeah yeah he's like so when you
see me I look [ __ ] great
y'all don't get any of this [ __ ] but you
know yeah yeah you should be happy that
I'm getting this yeah yeah when you look
at me it should be great you should feel
proud just look at me yeah you know
that's how it is in the military I know
yeah well there's lots there's other
like in the um in the corporate world
it's like that's it yeah yeah so it's
like I've experience also yeah where
it's and I'm just like what the [ __ ]
line are you trying to feed me to that
crap
everybody knows though get the [ __ ] over
here okay well that's what I said that's
why I can't really see any of that kind
of corporate crap because it's like
everybody knows that it's [ __ ] but
it's like we off to pretend that it's
not [ __ ] I'm just saying I don't
like that I'm not it's as real as you
make it
I don't want to make it real
I don't want it to be used I want it to
go away I want it to go away and I just
want them all to shut up
hold on Megan I gotta become Coney you
got to become Conan oh my God he's going
wigs already holy [ __ ]
don't let um don't let Pookie in there
she's been yelling to get in that closet
every time I open the door she walks in
and she's like well there's nothing in
here I'm like well duh that's what I
told you I don't know why she wants to
get in there so bad she's just gonna go
in there and climb around on [ __ ] all
right my hair coming oh you're doing the
hair okay
well I'm glad I didn't wear my long
black wig because
it would have been exactly the same you
can tell which one's yours because it's
all like um raggedy yeah because you
don't ever come makes it beautiful
because you don't ever brush it yeah
there you go I'm gonna have to brush it
you don't have to brush it no man it's a
little low it's natural on your on your
forehead yeah there you go good
I need my comb
you don't have a comb what are you
talking about
Cookie's excited she's like he's got
that thing he's got hair
she's like can I play it this is
Pookie's brush can I play with it yeah
it's got it's full of that Spooky's
brush it's got all Pooky hair in it see
I'm telling you man yeah
yeah she picked up the brush and she got
all excited yeah yeah she's like oh boy
Brushy is gonna happen no he goes it's
wig time yeah get on let's get on the
case yeah thank you finally man yeah
people are getting mad
well whose fault is that it's not my
fault yeah it is it's always your fault
there you go
now it's like British [ __ ] to the club
now I'm like distracted because you keep
saying that but it's like you know you
never do it's like you're always like
saying [ __ ] it's never comes to pass
it's just like all full of knots look at
that [ __ ] yeah okay go ahead and do the
show [ __ ] beautify different price
I mean we have been talking about
scientology to be fair
most of the time so it's a Scientology
show I just wanted to specifically kind
of talk about the Lisa McPherson case
although like okay so we're gonna get
like a little bit of background so we're
talking about L Ron Hubbard a little bit
from earlier
Back in 1970 apparently
L Ron Hubbard at his uh like advisement
or whatever
he started to do
um these things that they were gonna do
like these essentially like human
experiments okay on scientologists who
had like mental problems right because
he wanted to figure out you know how
they could solve them with Scientology
so they took these scientologists and
they would
like isolate them pretty much like they
would lock them up in isolated not let
them like talk to anybody no one would
talk to them and then they would go
through like all this weird what they
called like experimental processing so
they're trying to figure out the best
way to like have Scientology like cure
your mental illnesses right so they
would have like Auditors come in and
like do these this particular protocol
and all this other kind of [ __ ] and like
the people would after an auditor for
you people who don't know what she's
talking about and when you're gonna do
confession they put you on a lie
detector and it's an auditor that asks
you all these questions and reading the
damn lie detector writing it all down
record it's called an auditor like a
Confessor really what it is okay
but um but yeah so they would put these
people like I said in these rooms and
they wouldn't let them leave like even
when they wanted to so they were
essentially like keeping them prisoner
kind of and they would just like pepper
them with questions like I said for
hours and hours
um and actually like sometimes days I
think the experiments went on for like
days sometimes
so they went through all of this stuff
and then uh elrond that's what he used
to kind of write what um what the policy
was going to be going forward like
within the Church of Scientology like
how you would deal with people that had
mental problems like psychotic breaks or
something like that because obviously
you can't I mean scientologists if you
don't know are like super super against
Psychiatry or psychology of any of any
kind so they didn't want anybody having
to go to psychiatrists because
psychiatrists are evil apparently like
according to them what's their
competitors right yeah exactly that's
exactly what it is they're they're just
mad because you know although there's
evidence that psychology is just as
[ __ ] fake
holy [ __ ] I just realized 45 minutes
behind oh okay well
yeah I mean we started what like an hour
and 20 minutes ago or something like
that uh so yeah basically so they did
all these experiments on these
apparently unwilling people that were in
the Scientology called but they you know
I guess they didn't really sign up for
that kind of [ __ ]
but so L Ron in 1974
um he writes out what in Scientology is
called a policy letter
um you know that's saying like that's
laying out their policy on things
obviously and he said that from these
experiments these human experiments that
they did he had figured out how
um to cure psychotics and he had done
such a good job of it that um eventually
Psychiatry was going to be completely
eradicated remember when that happened
yeah no because that didn't happen uh so
the process that he came up with he
termed it the introspection Rundown
and basically what they would do is they
would take the person that was having
the psychotic break or whatever
um and actually in Scientology they
don't call it like mental problems or
psychotic psychotic break or anything
like that they call it pts type 3 that's
what they call it because they have to
have a [ __ ] word like that for
everything they always have to think
everything has to be an acronym or like
a weird [ __ ] sounding name and they
have like [ __ ] and this used to piss me
off too it's like they always have to
have a word they have that their own
words for [ __ ] that already have words
you know what I mean it's just like I
don't know it just like maybe really
well it has to sound like militaries
yeah all right okay it's like corporate
speak yeah is what it sounds like well
l-ron was military yeah and militaries
has its own language it changes over
time but it's a bunch of acronyms the
thing is the acronyms make sense when
you're in the military because you can't
say multiple multiple long-range launch
missile system or some [ __ ] like that
you know you so you're going to use an
acronym for that Humvee is an accurate
Hummer is based upon the acronym Humvee
highly mobile multi-wheeled vehicle it
just means it's like the replacement for
the Jeep
yeah
a wheel vehicle
so
we're using in the military we're using
these militaries and acronyms
for a reason it's real yeah you know but
it's yeah it's a real thing and it's a
quicker way it's a quicker way of
talking about something right because
you know the word
most of the words for equipment is a
description
it's not really a name for it you know
Hummer
Hummer comes from Humvee
highly mobile multi-wheeled vehicle
you're not going around saying bring me
one of them highly mobile multi-wheel
vehicles you know
so you're gonna say
give me Humvee
you know
it makes perfect sense
but these guys know
they're just pulling [ __ ] yeah well
they're they're it's a pseudoscience and
they're making they're making acronyms
based upon pseudo-scientific terms
but I think a lot of it is just to mask
the fact that they're not working with
anything yeah just to make things sound
more important than what they really are
yeah that's exactly what it is and I
think that's why it pissed me off so
much because it's like well because
sometimes if you read something that a
Scientologist wrote to another
Scientologist it sounds like complete
and utter gibberish yeah like I know
what some of it means because I knew
them and I worked at a place that was
run by scientologists for a while so
it's like I know what some of the terms
mean but it still kind of just sounds
like gibberish I'm like would you just
please like talk like a [ __ ] normal
person but they can't because like you
said it makes them sound more important
like there's more substance to it than
there actually is and it makes and it
sets them apart too like so they can say
all kind of [ __ ] without anybody knowing
culture speak yeah it is it's just it's
very irritating
so yeah so if you're pts type 3 that
means you're crazy essentially you know
what I mean
um so what they would do and you know
anybody that has anything that knows
anything about Psychiatry is probably
this is what you should not do like to
for a person that is you know having a
psychotic break or whatever what
scientologists decide to do
is they're gonna put you in complete and
total isolation
with no uh intellectual stimulation no
emotional stimulation uh you're not
allowed to really talk to anybody if you
do talk to people they're not allowed to
answer you
um people will kind of come in and take
care of your day-to-day needs but you
may not interact with them and for some
reason they think that that's gonna help
you that's the opposite that's actually
the opposite of what you should be doing
solitary confinement that's yeah and
they really think that's gonna yeah kind
of like sensory deprivation that'll
drive you crazy that won't [ __ ] drive
that's what I mean it's just gonna make
it worse what they thought was was I
kind of looked into what they believed
they believed that
um if you were going crazy it's kind of
like because you were over stimulated
so if you put them in solitary
they would get crazier and then it all
then it would stop
that they would even back out and become
rational yeah that's kind of like that's
like some Victorian [ __ ] yeah it sounds
like the Victorian yeah like you get
through it but that's not what actually
happens no
um or at least it might happen a lot a
lot of times
in the short term because the person
isn't really crazy they're just [ __ ]
pissed off because of some Scientology
policy say punish them put them in
solitary and they go well I better I
better behave or they won't let me out
of here right so then they get better
but a person who's really going crazy
put them in solitary they'll go crazier
yep they'll detach even further from
reality yep
and they won't have anything and I mean
that's why I just can't wait no way to
bring them back that's what I mean and
that's why this case is like so sad to
me and like just so [ __ ] tragic
because it was so avoidable it was just
so avoidable
and they just like [ __ ] her over
so yeah so no one's allowed to talk to
this person
um and apparently what this was supposed
to do like you said this person was
supposed to be in isolation with nobody
talking to them and they were supposed
to figure out for themselves like what
went wrong like why they have this
psychotic episode or whatever
and they would keep you in isolation
until you were able to come out and
explain exactly why you had gone crazy
and then they would let you out but not
until then like you had to be completely
mentally stable after however long you
were in there and explain like what had
gone wrong when a truly crazy person
doesn't know what the [ __ ] going on
well yeah that's kind of the whole point
I mean that's you have a psychotic
episode you don't know what's going on
like that's kind of the problem and
that's why you need other people to
intervene and maybe help you figure it
out you're not gonna be able to figure
it out you're the one that got yourself
into that the first place or like I said
you're you know you're not really aware
of like what's wrong you know what I
mean yeah again you talk them down you
give them some sedatives chill about
be normal try to get them to Shake It
Off
you want him to be in a normal
environment and a lot sometimes they'll
come back yeah I mean not always because
sometimes sadly like it's too it's it's
bad but you know what I mean yeah
um Adriana c said Tom looks more like Al
Jorgensen than Conan though yeah he does
yeah
um David June said Tom looks like Glenn
danzig's stepbrother who earned a
management degree in prison
that's a very specific and uh also very
accurate assessment yeah Tammy said
Tom's looking so pretty
David June said it's time a [ __ ]
princess the coping is extensive
he's trying to beautify the damn wig
well yeah I mean beautification
Tom's getting beautiful yeah are you
really this drunk already hold on no no
no okay you're acting like [ __ ] jerk
[ __ ] sober [ __ ] are you sure sober as
[ __ ]
the way you say that makes me doubt it
makes me doubt your statement just
you're trying to bring introspection in
on me don't make me introspect yeah yeah
I'm doing an interesting run I'm a man a
man aren't supposed to introspect okay
that only leads to heartbreak yes at
least they're heartbreak we're not
supposed to be examining ourselves we
just look at [ __ ]
although I I would argue that men not
just look at looking at themselves is
one of the main problems just looking at
[ __ ] in the world
no I've been here man I was on that
Trend I got that now it's it's it's
dangerous you become like a woman what's
wrong with that
they don't have any they don't we're
we're crazy we're not the ones crazy uh
hey we're not the ones out there being
serial killers hello no that's the
difference we're like shooting up places
different [ __ ] that's a dude thing yeah
okay so don't follow us crazy
it's just you know at least we usually
only harm ourselves if we get all like
[ __ ] crazy we don't take a bunch of
people out with us they shouldn't
shouldn't have [ __ ] with them just
okay don't [ __ ] they didn't [ __ ] with
nobody [ __ ] with them it's just random
she left that man alone
oh it's so you're blaming victims yeah
yeah you should have left that man alone
you did something no they did something
to him no made him mad no yeah that's no
excuse not in the back of the show I'm
mad all the time back to the show but
I'm not allowed to go Jenny's trying to
reason with me you can't reason with me
not reasonable
oh we're going back to that again yeah
now that I think I liked you better when
you were on the other one when you were
on the ship not reasonable David Chan
said I love you guys
Tammy said how sober is [ __ ] that's what
I'd like to know man you guys are asking
too many guys there we go assistant
David did you see the [ __ ] last week
where Tom was plastered yeah that's
right that was a Friday night show
so yeah you were just like barely
coherent yeah I don't even remember show
well he started like most of the time
you were just back there going yeah
I was like no I'm really on for like two
hours and I was just like what the [ __ ]
I'm nowhere near that that's like three
hours away
that's like three hours of drinking away
because that particular night I was at
the biker bar I was that's what I mean
he had been drinking I've been drinking
he had been drinking all out all [ __ ]
day and then Jenny came hung out I was
on a pole
yeah I was on a pole all the old biker
chicks were [ __ ] loving it
for at least as far as I can remember I
only danced for a few seconds all right
I don't know I didn't really see anybody
looking at you but okay not a girl next
to you a lady next to you oh I wasn't
looking at her yeah yeah
baby yeah she was also drunk yeah uh all
right so yeah so that's a little
background on the on the you know this
uh purification rundown or isolation
rundown or whatever it is that they do
um which plays a lot into what actually
ended up happening to Lisa McPherson
So Lisa McPherson
actually joined the Church of
Scientology in 1977 when she was 18
years old now she actually joined uh in
where she then lived and I think she was
born there uh as well she was from
Dallas Texas
now apparently I'm not sure what spurred
her exactly to join Scientology
specifically but At first she really
seemed into it like she thought that it
helped her out a lot in her life like I
guess she had been in a kind of an
abusive relationship with her boyfriend
and she said that the church like helped
her get out of that
um kind of helped her meet more people
you know get out and be more social
stuff like that and when she got in
there um you know she had all the you
know the job contacts and stuff like
that and that kind of helped her get um
a better job so in 1993 the company that
she was working for which like I said is
the same company that I worked for in
the early 2000s which is called AMC
publishing which was basically like what
they did was it was like a b like a
business to business
um thing where they would print out uh
at least when I worked there I don't
know if
um this was different like back in the
90s but they would print out these
packets of like uh like mail cards like
you know those cards you get in the mail
and you tear them in half and you can
like send one back it was like that but
they were selling
Insurance packages like two insurance
agents that insurance agents would sell
to the public you know what I'm saying
so it was like bigger insurance
companies being like hey we have this
package of like life car blah whatever
and then like here's this package that
you can sell to the public then I know
that's like sounds complicated but
that's what they did so I basically my
job was to like design like all these
little cards you know that's basically
it that you would mail to go through the
mail
so uh so yeah so she worked for AMC
publishing
uh and at that time uh it was owned by a
woman named benetta Slaughter and that
was the same woman who owned it when I
was there and I actually met benetta
slaughter a few times uh and her husband
I think was her husband David who worked
there as well
and uh most of the people that worked
there were scientologists I don't know
if it was most I want to say it was
maybe like 50 to 75 of the people were
scientologists now the company was
actually in Dallas Texas until 1993 but
then they moved to Clearwater Florida
that's because that's where I lived at
the time I worked there in 2002 I
believe it was
um and that's where it was then so you
know everybody's that's Clear Water
that's like their big headquarters like
the scientologists they own like a large
part of the downtown which you know a
lot of people that live in the city are
really all that happy about
so uh so yeah so Lisa is having you know
she seems to be doing okay she's got
this good job she's just moved to a new
place she's going up the bridge as they
say
um and she even kind of like I guess she
was kind of um you know reconciling with
the boyfriend who I guess was abusive
and uh you know
so she did that for a while but then it
kind of seemed like I'm not really sure
like what the timeline of this was
exactly because I mean she moved in 93
like to Clearwater and then you know the
thing that happened uh the horrible
thing that happened was in 95 so you
know so sometime over this two years
uh she kind of seemed like she was
getting disillusioned with the church
like maybe it was all getting like to be
a little bit too much for her
some friends of hers later said that um
she had been talking actually about
going back to Dallas and getting out of
the church like getting her life back
um you know getting her own job like not
being around them anymore so she did
seem to be according to several friends
of her she didn't seem to be thinking
about getting out of it
so in June of 1995
Lisa actually went to you know the
church higher-ups or whoever you go to
or these kind of problems and basically
told them that she was having emotional
problems psychological problems she'd
been thinking about suicide and she
really wanted to
um she really wanted them to help her
um friends she again she told her
friends she thought she was going crazy
uh you know she just wasn't feeling good
she was like I said contemplating
self-harm and she really tried to go
through the proper channels as they
would say in Scientology like to get
some help with her problems
um so basically they did an
introspection rundown on her
you know because that's their answer for
everything and it did seem to work at
first like it did seem to alleviate her
depression somewhat she'd still been
doing like all the Scientology courses
and [ __ ] like that like you know that's
they basically have you on these [ __ ]
courses you got to pay for all the time
and uh you know you got in your little
classroom I had to do it too even though
I wasn't even in the [ __ ] church but
when I worked there they had the first
half hour of the day you had to do that
their little stupid classes which I've
talked about that before it's like it
was like the stupidest [ __ ] ever this is
the biggest waste of time
um now interestingly uh according to
several different sources uh David
miscavige himself had actually was
actually managing her auditing sessions
right so David miscavage himself yeah I
don't know if he was actually auditing
her or if he like took a personal
interest and was like looking at all the
[ __ ] you know what I mean yeah
now in September of 1995
um they had this one of their big like
Scientology like Circle Jerks you know
what I mean like in the big [ __ ] you
know what they are you know like in the
big Auditorium or whatever you talking
about that it's kind of like the Oscars
yeah yeah Circle Jerks yeah so um so
yeah basically like a big corporate yeah
so they had say they had that and the
one that they had thank you David June
BTK tell my friends you're gonna murder
him looks like a wizard what
I don't know if that was is he asking
you to do the BTK voice you don't look
like BTK now with that hair no
BTK would
I don't what did you want me to do
I'm not entirely sure
BTK tell my friend you're gonna murder
him oh period okay looks like a wizard
who looks like a wizard he looks either
you look like a wizard or your friend
looks like or the friend looks like a
wizard that you're supposed to like
murder ah yeah that's how he's gonna get
it confused with Elrod Hubbard
laughs
I know you're his friend and everything
but I'm gonna have to kill you because
you look like a wizard
you can't look like a wizard
David Jude says threaten you'll kill
Gandalf
oh BTK
he actually might have been yeah he was
he was gay
so that's something BTK would just say
yeah yeah he wouldn't like it that was
like that that was it yeah you're
supposed you're supposed to understand
you're supposed to just be like oh yeah
yeah it was gay rather than like normal
people going and well that's what
Scientology did all the time I know
Scientology did that [ __ ] all the time
well they'd make if you piss them off
they'd make they'd build like a website
against you and like they'd say all this
and yeah and some of the people weren't
wearing this colleague so yeah
well that's what they did about [ __ ]
they were look they were seeing the
dailies at [ __ ] um this is this is uh
I think it's trying to remember who it
was which cult member said this it
wasn't it wasn't Rathbun it was uh
render Mike render Mike render Mike
render said that that uh miscavige and
some of the other ones would see like
the dailies from the making of the movie
uh [ __ ] uh battlefielders Battlefield
Earth you know and they were watching
John Travolta and they're like well
what's they were like these are like
what's up with this what's up with
[ __ ] John man what the [ __ ] and the
other guys you know what you know he's
out ethics you know you know the deal
but you know what they're talking about
is he's gay he's gay yeah he's out down
ethics he's out ethics that means you're
not doing Scientology you're not doing
Scientology right you're not ksw yeah
they wouldn't come out and say that he
was gay it's just that
they all evidently that was they all
knew and just The Insider way
to go and he's gay is when it came to
John travoltres they would just go out
ethics yeah about ethics
I mean that's what ethics means that you
know he's unethical right he's a sinner
but that's the thing it's like I wish
that you know even if he was I wish he
would just come out and say that and
just be that it's like I don't
understand like why it has to be this
big I can't confess I know I know and I
mean [ __ ] I I heard about this from
because I my aunt yeah uh she used to
because John Travolta I don't know if he
still has one but he used to have like a
big house like a with a lot of land in
Port Orange which is only like a few
miles from where I grew up and my aunt
ran a salon and he would in Port Orange
and he would come in there and get you
know facials and manicures and [ __ ] like
that and all the all the people that
work there like knew that he was gay
he's evidently like visibly outwardly
gay well that's what I mean like
everybody that worked there like knew
and he wasn't going around like God yeah
that's what I'm saying so it's like and
that and she told me that like back a
long time ago like back in the 90s but
when he's around the church he can't do
that yeah and uh if he comes out
the church will [ __ ] release all of
his [ __ ]
um confessions
all right and they'll come out and with
uh you know you were never a
Scientologist and all that Casting Couch
activity and you did this and that and
and you know they might have something
worse on him than that that so he can't
confess to that because if he confesses
to that he'll get kicked out of the
church
and if you get kicked out of the church
for confessing that they're gonna hit
you with everything they got let's see
the thing about it nowadays is I kind of
feel like one people don't care about
half the [ __ ] they think that people
care about nowadays anymore and two I
kind of feel like now Scientology like
most people kind of don't have that high
opinion of it anyway and I feel like now
is probably like a good time to do it
because if John Travolta just came out
right now and said yeah basically this
place this you know Church sucks or
whatever and then they say all this crap
about them I think it'll just only make
people like more like endear people more
to John Travolta and be like man those
church people are [ __ ] you know what
I mean I think it would kind of go down
like that they might have something
illegal on him
he's scared another thing is is that he
might like that church that's another
thing although somebody said like
earlier like a long time ago I think I
didn't get a chance to comment on it but
um somebody said that John Travolta was
like seemed like he was trying to kind
of like low-key distance himself from
that like he was selling some of his
property in Clearwater and [ __ ] like
that like he was trying to get the [ __ ]
out which like I said I can't [ __ ]
that's all you have to do really
um Scientology just doesn't want you to
soil their name if you slowly too late
that's just the way they see it he was
slowly just kind of fade away they don't
really seem to care that much
it's just if you come out and [ __ ]
say anything bad about them or you say
something bad about yourself which won't
reflect badly on the church they'll come
after you
so that's probably the best thing he
could do it's just kind of Fade Out
yeah yeah now Tom Tom Cruise he's like a
wed to that church he's actually
probably second in command you see you
know him and David miscavage that's like
his church
I don't think he's officially second in
command but probably in effect he's
probably a second in command yeah
um it can't go anywhere and I don't
think he wants to I think he likes that
I think he likes Scientology
what it offers him
because yeah he got a good experience to
me right he got a good experience from
them and I think he is a believer
I think he I think uh I think I think
what he what they call Scientology
training I think it helped him
um because he got he didn't get running
the middle Scientology [ __ ] he got
[ __ ] good [ __ ] all right and [ __ ]
that's probably not even in the book
they probably just [ __ ] taught him a
bunch of cool [ __ ] that has nothing to
do with psychic Scientology you know
there's no Talent
now he got in there he said that he
he said he had problems with dyslexia
but his girlfriend got him in there
I don't know if dyslexia is a code word
for not being able to read I don't know
it might have put your time I read
because they said that he would memorize
Scripts
that he would memorize he could hear a
script and memorize the whole thing was
he illiterate is that what they're
trying to do yeah maybe
that they taught him how to read
thank you again David June yeah
which is no shame in that [ __ ] you
know I mean some guy some dudes at their
backgrounds were that they never really
got a chance to read maybe they had
unstable family life never really got to
a school or something yeah I mean you
never know what anybody's like backed
story is so it's like you can't just
like [ __ ] on people just like yes I
learned to read late right you know
which like I said it happens yeah you
know some people don't have like uh
perfect upbringings and they had some
bad [ __ ] happen in their life you know
what I mean he's intelligent Tom Cruise
is intelligent yeah very intelligent
so it's not a reflection on that just
that I have a feeling he had an unstable
family life and an improper education
and didn't have good reading skills
that's what I think that he maybe could
read a bit but just not real good yeah
and that they completed his education
and uh he can't say that so he's got to
go to bat for him and then I think they
did a bunch of other stuff for them they
built whole complexes to him and his
girlfriends yeah so they did a lot to
seduce him
and he got high in that church
so I think he had a good experience but
he was just one person out of [ __ ] at
all those people you know
and there are some things that were in
Scientology trading that sound like they
could might be useful
because they're close to kind of like
Robert L Shooks
[ __ ] Hardball training sales training
techniques which yeah you know I had a
in a way kind of dominate Somebody by
asking them questions to filter them
down certain Pathways little tricks and
stuff like you'd learn out of a carnival
like what some of my mentalists might
might
learn
so they may have [ __ ] like that in there
in Scientology Trading
so
I don't laugh at everything in there
just a lot of it
well yeah I mean some of the stuff in
there yeah probably would help you
especially like in the lower levels yeah
you know not all of it's [ __ ] but I
think the stuff that's not [ __ ] was
stuff that was just taken from that was
either just common sense or stuff that
was taken from other sources these are
people that believe in mind Powers Yeah
okay so they might be teaching things
like that like it's not in the OT
training and not in certain manuals but
they might have some Side schools some
special schools to wear a [ __ ] circus
Mentalist or something went in there and
taught them how to do Mentalist tricks
and evidently some of that works you
could trick Somebody by asking them
weird questions
saying things to them and planting
subconscious imagery in the mind based
on the words some of it worked on me
through television
knowing what was underneath the dam
like this they had a dab a box and the
guy's telling you something he says you
will know what this is and I'm done with
it and like I knew it was a tricycle
before he opened it turned up as a
tricycle
because he had been saying things that
rhymed with tricycle
yeah they're like planting little
suggestions suggestions in your head
yeah it's not as hard to do as you right
so Scientology would be interested in
something like that yeah it wouldn't
surprise me if they have little courses
like that they teach this
select high level so let guys like Tom
Cruise basically yeah you know
and you might check back here what
rhymes with what I want I'm going to
keep saying this and they'll suggest it
into that person and they'll do what I
say you know what I mean it wouldn't
surprise me I mean you have to be kind
of good at it like so that people don't
like don't know what you're doing on to
what you're doing right but you know
what I mean like you have to be kind of
slick about it right
so if you're too obvious they'll be like
well you know yeah they wouldn't be like
that
um so yeah so where was I okay so
um early September of 1985. uh David
miscavige himself apparently at one of
the circle jerks like I said yeah
um declared Lisa a clear yeah
um and this is only like a couple months
before what happened happened so yeah
they said she was clear which means yeah
that's like
your big thing that's what you want to
achieve in Scientology
what yeah I said that a long time ago
okay I said a long time ago way ahead of
you
um so yeah so she was very very happy
about that like writing letters to her
friends like oh it's the most exciting
thing that ever happened she's clear all
this other kind of stuff
but then um only about a month went by
and she seemed like she was kind of
getting back to where she was having
depression and things like that
and uh so she went back to the church
for help like asking with about her like
psychological problems and stuff and
they did all these kind of you know
auditing and confessionals she had to
like
ever they have a thing too where you
have to like write everything down like
everything you write down everything
that that you [ __ ] up on and all this
other kind of [ __ ] so she had to do all
of that
um and she was kind of thinking that
this wasn't really helping her of course
as it wouldn't and she basically again
was like calling friends and saying um
yeah I think I'm gonna move back to
Texas I don't really want any part of
this anymore
um and she had also told her mom that
you know she didn't really want to be in
anymore and that she was probably like
having a hard time at her job which like
I said was all scientologists as well
now uh in November of 1995 uh she
actually went to a trade show with a
bunch of other people like from the
company and it was in Orlando uh you
know and I think that was kind of the
first time that a lot of people like
noticed that she was acting strangely
like several people noticed that she was
acting odd and that she was acting so
odd as a matter of fact that one of the
other co-workers
um kind of took her away from the trade
show early like took her back to
Clearwater
um she was able to kind of do a few more
things like she was volunteering with
this um you know Christmas thing that
they were doing but she was still like
acting real weird and so people were
kind of like huh that's not usually what
she's acting like
so then comes November 18th 1995.
Lisa is driving her Jeep Cherokee uh
toward downtown Clearwater
now up ahead like in the street there
had been kind of like a fairly my like a
motorcycle accident so the traffic was
kind of like stopped behind it while
they were clearing the accident now Lisa
um ended up running her car into the car
in front of her like had
um like a boat on the back of it like
you know it was pulling a boat so her
she ran her car into the boat motor okay
yeah
um now it was a minor minor minor
accident it's like there was no damage
to the boat
um and the driver of the car was
basically like it didn't feel like
anything
um now the grill of her Jeep was a
little bit [ __ ] up but that was about
it there was no injuries there was not
any massive damage nothing like that
now there was a paramedic who was up at
the motorcycle accident like up ahead
and she looked back and she saw this
other accident this little fender bender
and so she came over uh to Lisa
McPherson who was in the car and said
are you okay and Lisa said she was fine
so um the paramedic asked her a few more
questions you know are you sure do you
need to go somewhere or do you need to
see somebody and Lisa said no that she
was okay so the paramedic had a release
and said okay well you have to sign this
um you know to say that you're refusing
medical attention or whatever just so
they can't get their ass sued later on
and then she just like walked off and
went back to the initial accident right
so as they're packing everything up and
getting back in the ambulance the
ambulance driver looks back in the back
and sees Lisa walking down the street
taking off her clothes
and she starts walking down the street
like right by the ambulance like
completely naked
so at this point they're like okay well
clearly she's not okay
so the paramedic just gets out of the
ambulance and kind of like takes her
around to the back of the ambulance and
you know covered her up with a blanket
and stuff and it's basically like you
know what's the matter now Lisa says I
wanted people to think I was crazy
because I need help I just need someone
to talk to that's what she said
according to the paramedic
so they took her to the nearest hospital
which was Morton Plant Hospital in
downtown Clearwater
so you know obviously they want her to
get checked out because you know there's
there's something to matter now the
orderly's in the hospital said that she
seemed very distant and that she was
acting what they called robotic
um she didn't look like she was hurt
physically like they checked her out and
they didn't look like there was anything
wrong with her but they were like well
she's acting very strange so they
decided they were going to admit her
like you know for overnight observation
not too long after that though a whole
bunch of other scientologists started
showing up in the emergency room
apparently what had happened was that
benetta Slaughter who owned the company
that Lisa worked for
she had been driving past where the
accident was and she saw Lisa's
abandoned car like on the side of the
road and she asked like the cops or
whoever was there like where did they
take that person whose car that is and
they said oh they took her to the
hospital because she was acting funny so
benetta told a bunch of the other
scientologists hey go to the hospital
and get her like see what's going on
with that
and then here's the crazy thing and like
I said I met banana slaughter a few
times because she was you know the CEO
of the company that I that it was the
same company like she was still there
when I worked for it
um she was basically like well I'd go
myself but I was working on this charity
thing and I'm all covered with paint and
I look awful and I don't really do
hospitals anyway like she said some [ __ ]
like that I'm like yeah that sounds
about right that tracks but yeah so she
wouldn't go so she sent a bunch of her
minions like to go to the hospital and
see what was going well I didn't think
it was a big deal at this point with
Lisa yeah I yeah I'm not really sure so
I think they was I think there was like
a group of like eight scientologists
like went to the hospital to like see
what was going on
now they all who knows this chick's
gonna die she's just walking around from
their point of view probably would look
like throwing a temper tantrum yeah
taking her clothes off and he wouldn't
need help we don't have time for this
[ __ ] that's what they're that's that's
yeah pretty much right yeah and they
were afraid the scientologists were they
wouldn't really leave her side they were
kind of like crowding around her because
they were afraid that because she'd been
acting strangely like out in public that
they were going to call a psychiatrist
and that's like the worst thing ever
from like a scientologist's point of
view they think like scientologists like
the [ __ ] devil so they wanted to make
sure that that wasn't going to happen
so they did a physical checkup which
seemed to be fine like she seemed to be
physically fine
but then they brought in
um a nurse now he wasn't a psychiatrist
or a psychologist or anything like that
he was a clinical nurse but he had had a
background like he'd worked in a
psychiatric hospital previously so they
brought him in to you know see if she
was like to kind of assess her mental
state right
um and he said that he went in there and
like a bunch of the church members was
like crowding around her
now he managed to kind of get them out
of the [ __ ] way for a minute so he
could ask Lisa like look are they you
know keeping you prisoner or like do we
need to do something
um and she indicated at that time that
she wasn't being coerced by them
although I think that some people at the
hospital like thought maybe this wasn't
the case because the way she was acting
was like very very weird
um but they did say in the end that like
Lisa seemed kind of like bummed out
and she said she wanted to leave with
them like with the other scientologists
and the head doctor there was like well
you know there's nothing doesn't really
seem to be anything that matter with her
and she's not acting crazy enough for us
to like Baker actor or anything like
that which is you know what happens
usually if you're a danger to yourself
or others so like when she's not doing
that
um so there's no and she's physically
fine so there's really no reason for us
to detain her so if that's what she
wants she's an adult um so that's what
happened now uh interestingly like I
said
um several of the staff at the hospital
that interacted with Lisa or like kind
of saw her a couple of them did get the
impression that she was a prisoner of
these people like the way she was acting
but like I said there wasn't anything
legally they could do to like keep her
there
so after this
um the the other Scientologist the
little Scientology gang they drove Lisa
to the Fort Harrison hotel in uh
downtown Clearwater which was only like
a few minutes away from the hospital
so they put Lisa into room 174
um which is kind of like toward the back
of the hotel and they basically said
Okay She's you know like I said earlier
pts type 3 which means like she's gone
crazy and they said okay well we're
booking her into the hotel and she we're
doing an introspection rundown on her
which means that we'll have somebody
look after her like 24 7 but no one is
allowed to talk to her or interact with
her because she's got to sort her [ __ ]
out that's basically what they were
doing
so they start putting together the
little you know crew of people that are
going to watch over her now the woman
that was in charge of this [ __ ]
let's call it that was named uh Janice
Johnson now interestingly Janice Johnson
did have a medical degree and she had um
she had previously had a license to
practice in Arizona but it had been
revoked and then after she moved to
Florida she never bothered to get a
medical degree here so she actually was
not legally uh allowed to practice
medicine in Florida but you know that
clearly didn't stop her
so uh so yeah and the thing about it too
is that all of these other people that
they had supposedly like looking out for
Lisa like you know taking care of her
um most of them didn't really have any
medical training of any kind uh one of
the women uh named Judy Goldsberry Weber
she actually was a nurse but
um the other crew like didn't want her
helping out because I don't know I guess
they thought we don't want any like real
medical intervention or anything like
that but she was a nurse but the other
people didn't really have any clue like
what to do about any of this
so um so everybody would watch her like
in shifts right and then like they'd
have to write a report at the end of it
so people would be would watch her like
24 7 like I said but no one was allowed
to talk to her like even if she talked
to them or like asked for help or
anything like that you were specifically
not allowed to answer her because like I
said she was supposed to be sorting her
own [ __ ] out you're not supposed to
interact with her at all like even if
she talks to you
um and there was a security person
outside the room like at all times
and basically they were just gonna do
this until
she um magically got back to sanity
again that's what they were gonna do
they were just gonna keep her locked up
in this room and not talk to her that'd
make it worse well
spoiler alert that's what happened
that's what happened yeah she wanted to
talk to somebody you'd have [ __ ] talk
to her yeah they made it worse yeah they
did yeah yeah
um and clearly either because she was
going crazier or because she was just
trying to get out of this situation or
she thought if she escalated things that
maybe she would get some help from
someone someone else other than these
chuckle [ __ ] yeah
um so she so Lisa started acting out she
would start like people would come in
and then she would hit them she'd start
like acting crazy and like screaming
um take her clothes off like she would
[ __ ] in the bed
um they'd try to feed her she'd spit it
back at them all this kind of stuff she
was basically just like fighting them
every step of the way like I said I
don't know if this was because she was
actually having a psychotic break or if
she was just trying to act as crazy as
possible because she was hoping that
they would take her someplace where she
could get some actual help maybe both I
kind of suspect it was a you know a
little from column a little from column
B it might have been that frustrated as
[ __ ] that's yeah and I mean you can't
blame her you know what I mean so right
so they're just kind of like waiting
around for her to like so they're just
like taking care of her quote unquote
but she's just like freaking out and
like doing all this stuff
sometimes when a person does this [ __ ]
is because they know [ __ ] isn't right
the people around them are [ __ ]
saying it's okay but then it doesn't it
doesn't feel right to them like nah
right this isn't right man and then all
of a sudden they go am I crazy are they
crazy maybe I'm crazy so then they start
blaming themselves but what it is is
they're around about just round a bunch
of chuckle [ __ ]
she's around a bunch of I mean yeah yeah
she's probably like the only sane
[ __ ] insane right yeah she's
going she's having a moment of Lucidity
she's like this life isn't for me I need
to get out of Scientology but there's
nothing in her
realm of experiences you know what I
mean she doesn't know how to leave
Scientology so that's good it could have
caused a lot of problems you know what I
mean because I'm telling you I'm like
pretty aware of like I said even just
working around them yeah for and it
wasn't all scientologists like not
everybody that worked there was
scientologists a lot of them were yeah
but it's like even just working around
them and being in that environment
um you know if for a work day or like a
work week even that like after a few
months I started to feel crazy yeah you
can only lie in Gaslight for so long
eventually reality doesn't match up with
what you're being told and you can't
deny it you know what I mean that
[ __ ] that
what they're telling me is lying but
some people have very good imaginations
and like role playing [ __ ] abilities
so they can stay in in the fantasy world
they can they can they can continue
living the dream
but some people can't and that I think
that's what was happening here
she realized that she's being alive too
The World Isn't like what she's being
told it is and she she wants out of
Scientology is what it is but that that
but that thought hasn't [ __ ] dawned
on her yet
she's a Believer you know yeah so
there's a bunch of conflicts and [ __ ]
which like I said might have fueled like
why she was acting out what she needed
is she needed to talk to a normal person
yeah who understood what Scientology was
yeah like somebody that had gotten out
yeah and then somebody who could [ __ ]
go no this is what was what's happened
this is what they're telling you and
that's not the way it really is and now
you're not crazy you're just starting to
realize that they're full of [ __ ]
you need to come out of the church you
know it'd be [ __ ] like that that's why
she needed help she needed like a
deprogrammer yeah it's not just
Scientology there's [ __ ] lots of
[ __ ] religions and Cults are like
this where some of the members are like
they just they just don't have the
mental flexibility to [ __ ] believe
the [ __ ] anymore you know that's
what she's doing and they can't help her
and she doesn't really know what help
would look like anyway
so she's freaking out in that [ __ ]
cell fighting him because she's
frustrated yeah what you do is you
[ __ ] throw her ass out
maybe I think that's what she was hoping
would happen I think throw her ass out
in the [ __ ] field clean her up
put her in some civilian clothes listen
to some music
you know talk about something other than
the cult watch a movie
then [ __ ] you know get him to open up
over time
but you can't hit him with a bunch of
[ __ ]
anti-scientology stuff they'll reject it
they're not ready to hear that you just
got to get them away from it yeah
because a lot of times if you just come
out and be like oh they're crazy and
stuff they'll double down on this [ __ ]
and then they'll run back to it like
they see that and like I said culty
programmers will tell you that kind of
stuff too you gotta like ease them out
of it get them actually have them get
them doing something get them doing
normal [ __ ] and hanging around normal
people and like being happy and then
they won't need that [ __ ] anymore right
you know what I mean doing something's
totally unrelated to the cult right
that's kind of like the sad thing so
there's like other so there's reports
like they said at one point that they
actually like they had two women
um and I don't know if one of them was
her roommate who like I said I worked
with at the company because she was
still there when I worked there a few
years later but um they like kind of one
of them had each arm and they took Lisa
like back to her apartment I'm presuming
like to get more clothes or something
like that and like the apartment manager
saw them and said man she looked like
hell like she could barely walk and her
hair was all [ __ ] up and everything
like that so yeah she was just like not
she was just like really deteriorating
and like I said she was just acting
crazy but you know understandably
understandably acting crazy
now um they also said yeah I'm kind of
like reading because all these reports
didn't come out until later on they
actually do have a lot of the reports
other than the last three days and
before she died and that's we'll get
into that in a little bit but
talking about having her having bruises
all over and everything like that
um this one this is okay this is really
weird so
um on the 24th which I guess was like
the sixth day that she had been like
locked up in this room I don't know if
she was locked in there or she just
couldn't leave because they had a
security guard outside I guess they
didn't lock it because they had to go in
and out like to feed her and stuff
what ended up happening on the sixth day
was that I mean she'd been acting crazy
the whole time like I said she would
people would come in and she would hit
them she was like like I said [ __ ]
in the bed just all doing all that kind
of stuff spitting food at people
throwing [ __ ] doing stuff like that
but this one particular morning she
actually like um she got up out of bed
and she had nor she was I don't know if
she was clean but she had like normal
clothes on and then she opened the door
to the room and the security guard was
sitting there
and she talked to the security guard and
he said she talked like normal
and said she said what she said to him
was hey you're not CMO that means
commodore's messenger organization like
so he so he wasn't like a higher
authority like a higher ranking he was a
he was like a trainee or something right
and he's like um yeah you're right I'm
just like a trainee or whatever and then
Lisa said according to him you can't
tell me what to do
and then he said you're right
um and then he was like kind of he's
like oh [ __ ] I'm not supposed to be
talking to her because that's kind of
like one of the rules but he was just
like so flabbergasted that she had just
like walked out and was acting and
talking kind of normal for a change
um and also there's like there was
supposed to be somebody in the room like
watching her and they didn't know like
where they went
and basically so he just kind of like
you know pushed her back in the room
like gently and then basically what she
said then when she said I just don't
know what's happening
and then he realized that he wasn't
supposed to be talking to her anymore so
he stopped talking to her and then she
basically said could you help me I need
help and then he wouldn't talk to her
anymore because he realized he wasn't
supposed to so basically like shut her
back in the room
so you know
later that same day even though she'd
been acting normal earlier
um the head of security was called in
because Lisa was acting out again like
being really really violent
um actually one of the women that came
in that was you know trying to feed her
change her or whatever
um you know Lisa was smacking her like
you know kind of hitting her and um you
know she was kind of like she'd also
like thrown a bunch of like some
breakable [ __ ] so there was like broken
glass all over the floor and so they had
to have somebody come in and like sweep
the glass off the floor and [ __ ] like
that and also like one guy came in it
was kind of trying to like restrain her
and she grabbed his tie and then pulled
the pen like out of his pocket and was
gonna like [ __ ] stab him with it so
she did that too
um but basically they kind of like
restrained her right and then they were
like okay well just get the glass off
the floor like sort all this [ __ ] out
so at this point
um they decided she'd been in there a
week
and they're like well she doesn't seem
like she's getting any better and she's
you know physically violent every time
somebody goes in there she starts like
beating the [ __ ] out of them or like
throwing stuff and so then they decide
they're gonna sedate her
um so basically what they did was they
took like orange juice and then put like
Benadryl and [ __ ] like Crush that
Benadryl in it and then they would put
it in a turkey baster and then like
force it like down her throat like to
put her to sleep
so they did that
um because she like I said because every
time they went in there they couldn't do
anything because she kept like freaking
out and like throwing [ __ ] at them
um and basically and she hadn't been
sleeping either like she was awake all
the time so they were starting to drug
her
um they said that she's just in there
like talking screaming hitting things
um and also they said that she they had
to come in and like um kind of sedate
her a little bit so they could cut her
fingernails because they said that she
was scratching herself she was
scratching other people uh she had like
[ __ ] under her fingernails like so they
had to like soak her hands and like cut
them and cut the cut them short and [ __ ]
like that
so you know losing her [ __ ] mind yeah
well like I said not not surprising yeah
so November 28th
um you know like I said she's been in
there for more than a week at this point
and they said at this point well it
seems like she's calming down I'm
guessing because she's just getting
sicker and sicker she's getting tired
well and also she hadn't really been
sleeping all that well she had been
eating very much uh she'd mostly been
like refusing to eat
so she was probably like she was like
losing weight and stuff
and then they started like giving her
like magnesium shots
um who knows that's one of their like
[ __ ] Witch Doctor things yeah
um you know they kind of managed to get
like some protein shakes down here
sometimes but like a lot of times she
like I said she wouldn't eat
um but they never once until much much
later they never once called a doctor
they never once called an ambulance
nothing like I said that's not what they
they don't do that well they're
following Scientology protocol as for L
Ron Hubbard on how to cure somebody from
being crazy yeah which uh solitary
confinement is not a way to hear
somebody from being crazy yeah just a
protest that can drive somebody crazy
that's a torture solitary confinement
yeah they use that in prisons first that
is a punishment for a reason yeah
so she's basically this poor woman who
obviously has some issues although like
I said a lot of her behavior was
probably predicated upon like the
situation that she was put in not so
much you know her own mental problems I
would imagine
but so basically they never call a
doctor they never consult like any
medical professional or anything like
that you just have all these dumb asses
doing whatever like just following
Scientology [ __ ] like I said spraying
Benadryl down her throat giving her
magnesium shots and like not talking to
her and they're wondering why it's not
working
it's not working
um so yeah and at this point like I said
they said she seemed to be
from this point forward she seemed to be
like calming down because like I said
she had lost a lot of weight um you know
she was probably getting tired like you
said she's just like losing it and um
you know they tried to force feed her at
some point but she wasn't having it uh
could have been too that she was just
basically trying to die
like a slow suicide maybe
um you know
and so at this point uh December 2nd
she's kind of gotten a lot weaker
obviously but was still like hitting
people that came in there
and um she had they said that she had um
one of the one of the caretakers said
that she had scratches and abrasions all
over her body and her elbows and knees
she had pressure sores on them so
there's that
uh the 15th day so she's been like more
than two weeks she's been in this
[ __ ] room
um she was sleeping a lot of the time
and was basically too weak to stand up
and
um couldn't like she basically was just
like peeing and [ __ ] in the bed she
couldn't she was incontinent
um but they still the scientologists
still kept doing the same [ __ ] and how
long has it been now uh 15 days
15 days okay not a little bit over two
weeks yeah
okay
so it's not long when you think about it
no but I mean if she's going crazy they
should have got it and it's a long time
if you haven't slept or eaten or
anything like that it's a pretty long
time I would have given her a bunch of
sedatives and knocked her out that's it
well they did but it didn't work I mean
it worked to an extent but like I said I
don't think they knew what they were
doing they probably didn't even know
like dosages or anything like that like
I said they didn't ask none of them had
any medical knowledge yeah and it wasn't
it wasn't they didn't know what they
were doing and it wasn't an injection
they tried to make her drink it yeah I
had a shout her ass up with some milk
that's some kind of a
you know
a bunch of value maybe yeah
we're still on right because it's like I
haven't had we haven't had any chat in a
long time and that's unusual yeah yeah
it's weird we seem to be on oh okay I
was just wondering because Yeah because
sometimes yeah sometimes when that
happens
I'm on live chat I always change it I
just I mean it could be like that
happens sometimes but okay no I'm on
live chat there's there's more now oh
okay so maybe mine's just behind yeah I
think you're on top chat no I'm not it
says live chat right there I can see
I was just making sure because sometimes
if I don't get a chat like for a really
really long time that means I'm that I
lost my connection and didn't wasn't it
all right
um but yeah
so
yeah so she's still like I said refusing
to eat
and uh basically this okay so December
5th which like I said I guess that's
this was like the last day I guess this
was the 17th day
so two of the women
that had been caring for her they were
giving her a bath when
um
they said her sphincter relaxed what
which is that's never a good sign yeah
right
um now one of these women that was taken
care of her actually knew that this was
a bad sign because she actually had some
medical training unlike the rest of
these other idiots
so she's like okay um this is really bad
we really need to take her to the
emergency room like at least somebody
finally it's too late but okay
so they're like yeah she needs medical
care like immediately so she calls up
the Janice Johnson the lady that was
supposed to like in charge of this [ __ ]
show
um but it took two hours for this Janet
Janice Johnson person to show up to see
what was going on because I'm sure she
had really busy Scientology [ __ ] to do
and she comes there and she's like oh
yeah I guess Lisa's really dehydrated
and also she might be septic
now she calls up an actual doctor whose
name is Dr Minkoff who was also a
Scientologist he was a real doctor I
will give him that but he was also a
Scientologist
now he had um previously prescribed
drugs to Lisa but without seeing her
like he was just doing it like sight
unseen like from a distance which is
kind of a big No-No
now this doctor was working at a
hospital that was 45 minutes away
now the nearest hospital if you'll
remember was Morton Plant Hospital in
downtown Clearwater which was only a few
minutes from the hotel guess which
emergency room they went to the one that
was 45 [ __ ] minutes away because they
knew that the doctor that was on duty
there was a Scientologist I thought they
could trust him he could keep it silent
yes yeah yes
so they put this poor woman in the back
seat of the car laid her down in the
back seat of the car
and drove past three emergency rooms and
finally got to this one that was 45
minutes away so it was extra half hour
drive
yeah actually more than that it was an
extra 40 minutes extra 40 minutes
because the closest hospital was like
five minutes away I wonder if 40 minutes
would have made the difference between
life and death with her it might have uh
it might have it might have been too
late I mean it it very well might have
been I mean there's really no way of
knowing right because it's too late now
like I said
um I mean she was still alive when she
was in the car but they said that she
was kind of like deteriorating like all
the way there just because a person's
alive doesn't mean you can help him well
I know that but I'm just saying I'm just
saying that there's no way of knowing
that now right
if they had gone to the nearer place
like she might still be alive she might
not they might it might have been too
late like I said one way or the other
but it was just a stupid thing to do
like once they realized that that the
situation was that critical I mean duh
obviously you would go to the closest
place I mean a normal person would
unless you're a [ __ ] Scientologist in
which case yeah
so you'd rather have somebody die than
go to somebody that wasn't a [ __ ]
Scientologist which is stupid well they
felt they could trust those people their
mentality is is it's an US versus them
mentality
yeah the scientologists would be able to
keep it quiet if anything went wrong
but it's probably more like we'll send
them to a Scientologist he won't charge
us as much money or maybe any money
and uh he's a good person well we don't
we know he'll take care of yeah
everybody else everybody else they might
hurt her she's a Scientologist like no
you guys we didn't get about them
they're no good we can't trust them
they're no good they're not you know
they're not watching out for us so I
think I think it's more of that than
anything else yeah I think it is too but
like I said that's a stupid stupid
mindset very stupid
so they see non-scientologists as
[ __ ] incompetence of humans
you know what I mean which is crazy to
me because it's like yeah you've had
this poor girl in your custody for like
more than two weeks and like look what
you guys did yeah talking about
incompetence well they got that [ __ ]
directly from the source all around
Hubbard could you guys [ __ ] it up now
Ron however's not gonna be wrong Ben
said their biggest concern is probably
that she would be committed yeah I mean
that was definitely like right after the
initial car accident happened that was
definitely their biggest concern yeah
they're afraid if she's committed then
she'll fall into the hands of the enemy
and they'll kill her they'll never
[ __ ] get her straight because they do
not believe in [ __ ] any kind of
psychology or psychology Psychiatry any
kind of mental health treatment yeah so
they think they got that [ __ ] covered so
yeah they don't you're right they didn't
want her [ __ ] committed yeah and
they think that that's death yeah so
yeah
um so basically they did have a
statement um and like I said a lot of
these statements I think came from um
you know because there was a trial and
[ __ ] like that afterward and like you
know various other records and
investigations that went on afterward
but um they talked to a nurse who saw
that the hospital who saw them bringing
her in and she said um that yeah she
knew immediately that things uh were not
good she said that Lisa looked very pale
she said her eyes had this really hazy
look to them and she wasn't breathing
now she had been breathing in the car
apparently but when they brought her
into the hospital she wasn't so they
took her into the CPR room and did
started doing CPR
um but the nurse was like I'm pretty
sure that she was you know essentially
like dead when she got here
um you know they did they bring her they
brought her in they did like put in IV
they did all the stuff they were
supposed to do and they worked on her
for like a really long time but um they
could not revive her so yeah they
pronounced her dead shortly afterward
now uh the same nurse who saw her coming
in thought there was like some kind of
fishy [ __ ] going on with this [ __ ] and
she was right
so she called the cops and good for her
like that here and her she was you know
she got involved she was like I don't
think this is right
so because her body like if you've seen
like the the photos like autopsy photos
and stuff like that she looked [ __ ] up
so the nurse was like yeah I'm pretty
sure it's something suspicious yeah he
saw those photos he's like what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] up
um so yeah so the Clearwater Police uh
you know came in and said yeah we're
gonna start an investigation
now as soon as that happened uh the
scientologists go on what they do uh
they they have to have come up with a
cover story you know except they call it
a Shore story that's what they call it
that's what they tell all the Rubes
that's that's their story and they're
sticking to it
what they did so they certainly Cobble
in a story together also the room that
she'd been in at the Fort Harrison hotel
they completely cleaned it out
and for whatever reason they took out
the room had because it was like a hotel
kind of like a resort type thing they
the room that she had been in had two
queen size beds for some reason they
took both of those out and just put one
king size bed in there I don't know what
the implication of that was but that was
one thing they did and they totally
cleaned it like stem to stern
um so they did that
and then they kept kind of all the the
people that had been taking care of her
they kind of kept everybody in one they
tried to get everybody's story straight
is what they were doing
um so Marty Rathbun who we've talked
about
before
he was actually in on this he was
because he was very high up in the
church at this time and it was his job
to handle the kind of the blowback from
this
so basically what he did
um he had to take all anything that the
church had paperwork like her auditing
folders anything like that that was
pertaining to Lisa's [ __ ] and send all
of it to La which is where uh David
miscavige was back then like send her
send him all the stuff
but Marty said the reports that
everybody because they scientologists
have like they write everything down
they report everything they're kind of
like Nazis in that way they well no it's
like what they have to kind of like keep
records like no matter how [ __ ]
horrible it is they have to like keep a
record of it I don't know it's like
pathological but so it's all military
yeah they had like all so they had
records of like everybody because
everybody that went in to check on Lisa
like in the last three days before she
died they wrote down exactly what
happened and like what she ate was like
oh she hit me or blah blah you had to
write out a report
so for the last three days before she
died Marty basically came in and said to
the people about the paperwork for those
last three days he said lose them yeah
and they've never been found they've
never been found yeah
the those last three days but they have
all the other ones like those but those
reports were not for Outsiders they were
frozen yeah it was like for in well
that's what all their [ __ ] is right all
their [ __ ] is like supposed to be kept
internal so and if you release it to the
public you know they'll have a [ __ ]
fit they'll have a fit top secret
documents God damn it yeah from The Cult
yeah well because like that's why they
have such a freak out about like like I
said like Marty brathman who left but he
still believes in it and you know him
like
trying to like teach people Scientology
for free they will try to suit your ass
off if you do that because it's like
that's you know privileged information
that's like our secret Scientology top
secret religious [ __ ] and you can't tell
people that it's a shame because this
group had quite a bit of level of
organization a lot of money they got a
lot of nice properties
um they had cute girls working in the
cult
um
but this isn't really about anything
that's the problem if they were really
kind of like
if it was real topical and there was
like they really were trying to do some
cool [ __ ] this would be a cool
organization but it's just kind of it's
not really based around anything no
there's a bunch of lunatics
they're lunatics it's funny how you
think they're like smarter and more
awesome than everybody else on Earth but
they're clearly lunatics it's just
really [ __ ] bizarre that you can make
an organization of this size and
complexity and sophistication over
nothing
really isn't that insane yeah I know
that's what I mean it's like it's I I
kind of feel like you we talk about it
sometimes and like when you talk about
it it sounds absurd like this [ __ ] if
you put this in a book like before it
existed no one would believe you no but
it exists they do all this [ __ ] it's
crazy they have a system of almost
military-like [ __ ] bases everywhere
some of them out in the desert some of
them up on top of these mountains and
[ __ ]
and this sounds like some out of a James
Bond movie
it does that's what I mean it sounds
like some kind of weird like [ __ ]
Specter yeah they got [ __ ]
you know they got ships and stuff I
heard they for a while they had back in
the day red eye missiles some [ __ ]
anti-aircraft missiles on that ship
[ __ ] I don't know if it's true
um some
a lot of them had guns they had training
and stuff but select members
um
and they're trying to do mind powers
like they're Jedis
it's just [ __ ] hilarious you know but
they
that they made and it's huge they have a
[ __ ] ton of money this is nice stuff
that they have
and it's just funny it was all kind of
like built on these little self-help
books
written by a dude who's a [ __ ]
artist you know I don't think he's a bad
man he wasn't a bad man he was just
bullshitting yeah be [ __ ]
you know
the world's a strange place it is and uh
I think I'm kind of about something and
I can't build something like that
well see that's the hell of it isn't it
like a lot of times like if you if
anything of substance it's not yeah
[ __ ] sells better than real [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah that always kind of like
bombs me out yeah I guess but yeah so
yeah so not only did Marty rathman
basically say hey like you know throw
those three days of notes down the
memory hole but also
um three of the women the scientologists
that had been uh I think it was all
women
that had been involved in like taking
care of her like while she was there
they uh abruptly left the country
so that's not suspicious we went to
another Scientology Oregon somewhere
else yeah because they have them all
over the world and except in countries
where they're illegal you know what I
mean because they are in some places
Russia kicked them out well a lot of a
lot of European countries I don't think
they're
Sandra's not here to ask anymore but I
don't think it's legal in Germany either
I'm pretty sure Germany saw through this
[ __ ]
so uh so yeah so the whole story that
they constructed about what happens to
Lisa McPherson was that they said okay
well she came here of her own volition
for what they called rest and relaxation
because she was just like kind of
stressed out you know what I mean not
like she was having a psychotic break or
anything like that
um and they said you know she was at the
hotel everyone was checking on her she
seemed fine she was relaxing
um but then on this on day 17 she got
fast acting meningitis
that's what they said and we took her to
see Dr Minkoff
um because that was who she requested
even though he was 45 minutes away she
wanted to see him because he was a
Scientologist and um but then she died
that was their story
so uh basically
so the cops were just kind of like huh
okay um I don't think so so the cops
actually went to the Fort Harrison hotel
to do an investigation and like I said
when they went into the room where she
had been
um it was all cleaned it had all been
done out like the furniture had been
replaced like everything like that which
again gee not at all suspicious is it
then they interviewed like a bunch of
the people that had been taking care of
her and they said to a man they all said
the exact same story that all the same
quote-unquote short story that they had
agreed upon they all gave the exact same
details
um but unfortunately for the
scientologists other people had seen
some [ __ ] to happen too because uh one
they had the autopsy photos and they
said well a lot of that stuff is not
consistent with what you're saying
happened and also the paramedics that
had seen her
um you know after the initial accident
they thought that she was like normal
weight they thought she was maybe 130
140 pounds when she died she was 108
pounds damn
um so yeah so she had lost that much
weight in like a little over two weeks
yeah so a lot of that dehydration well
yeah that's what they think was one of
the causes of death was dehydration
so yeah and that's the thing too and
also the cops were very suspicious that
it's like we don't care if she did ask
like after she was in this shitty of a
condition you should have taken her to
the nearest hospital and not driven her
like four [ __ ] hospitals away like 45
minutes
um and because she was probably already
dead when she got there so the cops were
really not buying it
um now basically it's kind of like so at
this point but not a Slaughter like I
said the women that owned the company
where Lisa Works she calls up
um Lisa's mom whose name was Fanny and
told her that she died and that and
Vanetta straight up lied to Lisa's mom
and basically saying oh well
um she just suddenly got sick like she
was fine up until that last day and then
all of a sudden she's got sicker and
sicker and we took her to the hospital
and she died it was meningitis we don't
really know what happened so she
straight up lied to the girl's mom which
is that's [ __ ] up
um they also didn't tell the mom because
the mom I think was still back in Dallas
they also didn't tell the mom about the
car accident didn't tell him about the
whole introspection rundown thing didn't
tell him about any of that stuff
basically their story was yeah she just
showed up here and then she suddenly got
sick and she died the end that was like
the thing that's what they told her
[ __ ] mom so you know what I mean uh
so the mom also wasn't buying it
so the mom like flew to Clearwater to
kind of figure out what the [ __ ] was
going on too
and uh basically the mom said the mom
and the sister like when they got there
they said they'd get to Lisa's apartment
because you know they wanted some of her
things like her personal belongings and
stuff and they said that when they got
there her roommate and a bunch of the
other scientologists were like taking
stuff away they took like all her [ __ ]
and I think too that her um personal
bank account had 11 left in it like when
she died so they also took all her money
that's what they're assuming oh no
scientologists didn't have much money
they don't pay him much how much did
well wait a minute was she still well
she had yeah yeah well she worked well
she had a normal job okay she was public
then yeah she had a normal job she
wasn't like sea org or anything like
that okay so but yeah that's the thing
yeah she donated all her money to pay
you know what they did they took her
[ __ ] to pay for her treatment
probably yeah they did yeah that's the
way scientologists are none of that it's
just free you're not a freeloader
they'll charge you for being a
freeloader yeah yeah and they won't tell
you about it either like you'll only
learn about it like after the fact yeah
you'll be oh by the way you owe us this
much money in the sea org for [ __ ] 10
years all right [ __ ] living like a
slave not even getting paid
eating their [ __ ] slop and then
they'll kick you out over some kind of
[ __ ] out ethics or something you know
what I mean you did something wrong and
then they hit you with a bill for forty
thousand dollars freeloader yeah
freeloader bill you live for 10 years
here we're gonna charge you for that bed
you were sleeping in even though you
worked for them no you worked that whole
time yeah because your labor isn't worth
it yeah to them you know what I mean so
it's that and they never have the money
to pay for that [ __ ] it's just sucks
even if they did it's like what they
can't legally come after you for that
like eat a dick I'm a Scientologist
though the way the way they're they're
so mentally screwed up they try to pay
that they probably would of course they
would but it's like they don't have any
legal standing they can't make you pay
them it's like it's fine just ignore
them but um you know what I'm saying but
yeah so and that kind of this kind of
thing freaked me out too because when
the mom and the sister came and saw like
the roommate and I was like I knew
Lisa's roommate she worked with me I
can't like I said I can't remember what
her name was but she worked at the same
company as I did
and everybody like somebody else at the
company said yeah that that was the
woman that lived with Lisa like when
Lisa died and so the roommate and all
the other scientologists like went in
there and like took all her [ __ ] like so
her mom couldn't even get any of it like
I think she got a couple items of like
clothing or something like that but most
of the [ __ ] was already gone so
Stay classy Scientology you know what I
mean Jesus Christ
um so you know and the mom is like she's
like asking look can anybody tell me
what really happened and like none of
them would tell her anything which again
made her like this like super super
fishy right now it so happened
that even back in 1995 uh a lot of
people in Clearwater uh did not like
scientologists and were and protested it
like all the time and they had already
been planning a protest for that
upcoming spring I think it's supposed to
be like in March of 1996. and
um it so happened that they were meeting
with the cops um you know kind of
planning the protests it's like hey
where can we go like legally and is this
going to be okay with the ordinances and
all that other kind of stuff and
somebody in the police like happened to
tell them about Lisa McPherson dying and
they recognized the address like as the
Fort Harrison hotel because that was
where they usually protested so a couple
of them started looking into it being
like Oh my god what happened to this
girl did they kill her so
um at that point
um they kind of went to uh like a woman
that worked at The Tampa Tribune like
one of the main papers over there and so
they um they kind of like collaborated
like the protesters on the newspaper
lady and they're like um okay we need to
find out like what the [ __ ] went on here
because the scientologist's gonna lie
about it because they knew him they knew
the score on that in that regard so um
so basically what they did was that I
mean that was kind of the way the story
came out like with the protesters like
kind of getting up with the newspaper
people because they knew somebody that
was in the cops and they figured out
what was going on
so they do um an autopsy and like I said
Zach the you can see the autopsy photos
online it's like you know I wouldn't
recommend it because they're pretty
nasty but you know what I mean they're
there if you want to see them
um so they do the autopsy
now uh the first guy that was doing the
autopsy who's the assistant Emmy the
medical examiner he actually never
finished it because they asked somebody
like asked him to resign I think there
was like a lot of weird like nefarious
[ __ ] going on behind the scenes with
this [ __ ] here so the report that was
eventually finished
um they the cause of death on there was
a thromboembolism of the left pulmonary
artery caused by bed rest and severe
dehydration
so they basically ruled the death
undetermined so like it wasn't an
accident it was a homicide but they just
kind of like left it ambiguous I guess
um the autopsy report also had like they
had there was a bunch of bruises she had
a bunch of bruises um like there was a
like an abrasion across her nose and a
bunch of very famously a bunch of insect
bites like she was covered with
cockroach bites so there was that too
yeah they were headed up and I think it
was big blue was the name of the
building that they had her at wasn't it
at Big Blue well Fort Harrison uh
where's that Clearwater that's what I've
been talking about this whole time yeah
so it's not big blue
okay yeah that one over there evidently
uh
yeah in places infested with roaches
they said big blue was infested with
roaches too so I don't know maybe that's
a Scientology thing yeah maybe they
don't clean [ __ ] up or I don't know I
don't know what it is although like I
said it's to be fair it's Florida pretty
much everything's expensive approaches
to some degree
um so yeah
so the autopsy report like I said the
assistant uh medical examiner got asked
for resigned so the autopsy report got
completed by uh the supervisor whose
name was Joan wood now June wood the uh
you know the the main Emmy she was
actually she went on TV she was on that
remember that show Inside Edition she
went on she went on that show like in
early 1997 and she said that you know in
contrast to what the Scientology like
scientology's [ __ ] story that they
were trying to Pedal she said on TV that
the autopsy showed that um that Lisa
McPherson's condition had deteriorated
like over a long time like that she had
clearly been without fluids for between
five to ten days she was drastically
underweight
um she had been she probably went into a
coma 24 to 48 hours before she died uh
she was covered with cockroach bites
like I said
so you know clearly this whole story
that Scientology told about her suddenly
getting meningitis and dying from it was
clearly not true because she's like this
looked like it took like a very long
time
at that point uh as they do
scientology's Phalanx of lawyers uh
tried to sue her
um you know because they're basically
like well you [ __ ] up your [ __ ]
because you went on TV and like said all
that stuff and they also wanted
um they sued because they wanted to get
access to uh all the files that the
medical examiner had that had like all
the stuff about
uh you know blood samples and stuff like
that like from Lisa McPherson's body
um so basically their their argument was
well because you went on TV and talked
about it and made it public then you
shouldn't be able to keep your the
records closed because you already
blabbed them to everybody so we should
be allowed to have them or like see them
you know what I mean so that's what they
did now I mean honestly because they
asked for them before and the
authorities were like absolutely not
because it's like an investigation right
so they wouldn't let them have them but
so they were trying to sue like to to
look at them
now interestingly another newspaper of
the Saint Pete Times uh they also went
to a bunch of other medical experts to
kind of get like back up on this like is
that autopsy report correct and uh five
other medical experts uh said the same
thing they said yeah that's you know
that that's looks like what happened
like that looks consistent or whatever
so um because Scientology like I said or
mad little [ __ ] um they hired their
own team to argue against what the
medical examiner and all the other
experts said now two of the people that
they got were actually like legit like
experts I guess they were like forensic
pathologists
um so they actually got them to say and
I'm not sure how they did this
but they got them the two of them to say
that Lisa McPherson had died suddenly
from a blood clot in her left lung
that had originated from like she had
maybe hit her knee like during the
initial car accident and then it like
traveled too car accident yeah so that's
they actually got to like legit
Pathologists to say that I'm not
entirely sure how I don't know if they
had some dirt on them or paid them off
or whatever the [ __ ] both maybe both
[Laughter]
I looked at her Channel she's just a
narcissistic housewife narcissistic
that's what she said
Oh I thought you were just being mean no
no no no she's cute she's just just
another Channel she's got a lot of
videos and stuff okay
yeah uh but yeah so they got the two
Pathologists to say that so
um so basically what happened so then
they were like arguing over because of
course it was to the scientologist's
benefit to say that she had just come
there of her own volition and then had
died suddenly and it was of course not
their fault so they were mad at the
original
um report which said that she clearly
died over a very long period of time and
had lost all this weight and was
dehydrated and bloody blah so you know
so they're saying no she was already
skinny when she came in and all this
other kind of crap it was just it was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] show like I said
um so yeah
now what ended up happening with this
because there was such there was a big
argument about it so then they have to
bring in like this little review board
to kind of like sort out what the [ __ ]
was going on to like see if anything
that the Scientology team was coming up
with was legit it's like you know what
are we gonna do about this now after the
review it should be noted the original
medical examiner changed her cause of
death from undetermined to accident
and put on there that about like maybe
the auto accident maybe caused some kind
of like blood clot or something like
that so again not really sure what's
going on there like I don't know if the
Scientologist got to her and they were
just kind of like hey we know about this
that and the other thing or here's fifty
thousand dollars or who knows but you
know she changed the [ __ ] right on the
autopsy report which
you know a cult member will do anything
for the cup yeah that's that's what I'm
saying I didn't cost him any money
uh-huh
probably got some free OT training we'll
bring you up at OT level just anything
oh boy yeah yeah you'll level up can't
wait your wizard skills yeah
can't wait man if they really gave me
Wizard skills they'd be in big trouble
because I'd lightening both their heads
right now
but yeah so anyway
um so basically so they asked this woman
like the Emmy like what the [ __ ] like
why did you change what you put on your
initial report and she came up with some
kind of story about oh well you know
just you know if it's all this technical
medical stuff but it's like oh I kind of
realized blah blah but basically it was
something that she said that she missed
the first time even though nobody could
understand like how she could have
missed it the first time like if she'd
done her job competently you know what I
mean I kind of suspect that the
Scientologist kind of like got to her
and maybe they threatened her I don't
really know
so basically because she had changed the
because they had done this review and
because she had changed you know the
thing from undetermined accident so
there was a criminal case pending about
Lisa McPherson's death but it was
dismissed at that point because it's
like oh well now there's no criminal
anything
um so basically they did
um that's the thing
so like the um what do you call it the
assistant State Attorney whose name was
Douglas Crowe at the time he wrote this
big long memo and he sent that to the
state attorney and he's like well we got
to drop the criminal case because you
know we don't have this he's like he
thought that there was still probable
cause like he still thought there was
like some weird [ __ ] but he's like but
the fact that the me changed her story
um and kind of like threw a monkey
wrench in the whole program so it's like
we don't really have enough credible
evidence at this point because she keeps
like changing her [ __ ] so we don't think
that we'd be able to get a conviction so
you know basically he was like well
what's the point because you know we
don't think we're gonna get any charges
now um so the thing that happened after
this though which like I said you have
this lady whose name was Cheryl waldrip
um and she was a reporter at The Tampa
Tribune and she was basically watching
this [ __ ] show and also she thought it
was really weird that um that there had
not been an obituary like run for Lisa
at all
so she actually kind of got together
with Lisa's family and they sort of
collaborated and so they she wrote this
big long
um story like in the paper it was like
front page
um and it was basically called uh
mystery surround scientologists death
and so from that point forward it kind
of seems like the media and protesters
and the family of Lisa McPherson just
kept like hitting Scientology about it
because you know Scientology obviously
they were trying to like spin this story
it's like oh they didn't have any
culpability in the whole thing but
everybody else like just started like
chipping away at it because like
obviously this poor girl died in their
care and obviously something they did
was responsible for that to some degree
and people wanted like some [ __ ]
Justice done so Lisa's family actually
sued the Church of Scientology in 1997.
for wrongful death and so the court
actually ordered them to turn over all
the caretaker logs which is where a lot
of this stuff came from other than like
I said the last three days which had
been lost forever apparently and
um in 1998 in late 1998 actually the
State of Florida
um charged them as well actually
specifically the flag Services
organization yeah
um they charged them the State of
Florida charged them with uh abuse of a
disabled adult and practicing medicine
without a license yeah
um so basically a description of what
happened yeah and well it's like they
didn't want to go I feel like they
wanted to go for some greater charges
but they thought those would be like
safe because they were kind of a little
bit low level but still it's not murder
they weren't trying to kill her right
they were trying to help her but they're
just they're not doctors but they're
just idiots
so uh yeah
and um
so basically after that like I said
about the protesters before that had
already been planning a process
um you know around that like a different
time so what they started doing though
was they used to protest around uh L Ron
Hubbard's birthday uh which was in March
but they started changing it to the day
that Lisa McPherson died which was
December 5th
um and they started like they started
early like that year and they started
doing like Candlelight vigils and stuff
scientologists would come out and like
blow their candles out and [ __ ] like
that what a bunch of dicks I mean
seriously can you be any more dickish
than that
I mean well yeah but it's just like
Jesus Christ what's what's the name of
that organization which one
part of the sea orgas they're it's their
uh intelligence [ __ ] agency it's not
OSS is it what's it I thought it was Osa
Osa yeah
what happened going out there to [ __ ]
you blow those candles out you blew this
candle yeah Osa that's what it is that's
their version of like the CIA
or FBI yeah
yeah they have their own version of
everything yeah it's ridiculous yeah
it's busted up into a bunch of different
uh divisions and departments and it
it has its own intelligence in the inter
internal security department Osa
it's like their version of the FBI
but it's also kind of like an
intelligence agency it's like the CIA
and they're not a joke man they did the
largest penetration of the [ __ ] U.S
government of all times was done by
[ __ ] Scientology yeah the IRS yeah
the IRS and also the FBI they
infiltrated the FBI it was called
operation of Snow White
where they sent all those damn cult
members to go get jobs with the US
government and they got jobs because
they were qualified got in there and
they were [ __ ] given up government
secrets to the cult and all because L
Ron Hubbard thought the FBI was after
him
he wanted to know what the FBI knew
about him and they didn't know anything
they didn't give a [ __ ] about him
he didn't care about him well that's
what was ironic about it was like if he
hadn't done that he probably just could
have operated without but he's like oh
what do they know about me it's like
nothing was like oh well now we're
interested because what the [ __ ] are you
up to yeah they didn't know anything
about it and [ __ ] didn't care about
him right I'm like but now they do you
just called attention to yourself
hilarious Swift so so yeah operation
Snow White look it up so we're gonna be
right there on Wikipedia yeah it's
ridiculous and then [ __ ] like I said
if somebody made this up nobody would
believe it and they got busted and L Ron
Hubbard blamed it all on his wife and
his wife went to prison for him yeah
yeah I ain't that some [ __ ] like I said
Stay classy science yeah I wasn't in
charge of that department my wife was in
charge of that department
I didn't know she did that
yeah she was I have no idea yeah yeah
okay
so so yeah basically all right so
um 1999 the Lisa McPherson trust uh they
opened it up only a couple blocks just
to rub it in the face only a couple
blocks away from the Fort Harrison hotel
and their whole thing was basically just
telling everybody like about how [ __ ]
horrible the church were
um I think that was kind of started by
uh Lisa's mom now unfortunately like she
died not too long afterward but you know
and I don't think the trust is around
anymore but it was around for a little
while uh Dr Minkoff the guy the
Scientologist doctor that they drove all
that way to see
um he actually had his license suspended
in 2001 uh thankfully uh not for killing
her but for prescribing medicine to her
without having seen her which like again
that's a big No-No so he had his license
suspended for that
um so I kind of feel like maybe this
case I know a lot of people maybe didn't
know about it at the time but I think
this might have been I don't want to say
like the beginning of the end because
these [ __ ] are still around but
I think this was the beginning of their
kind of downward slide where people
actually were kind of waking up to the
fact that they weren't just like this
funny little jokey punchline cult like
oh what a bunch of weirdos that they
were actually like kind of dangerous and
yeah and that maybe we shouldn't be like
tolerating it you know what I mean they
were they were kind of sophisticated
enough to be a threat right
um I kind of feel like this was maybe
the first
and kind of delusional enough to be
dangerous they're they're delusional
yeah
yeah that's what I mean so but I do
definitely feel like and like I said
this was 95 so when when she died and I
know that maybe like it didn't really go
mainstream I feel like until
probably like I want to say the South
Park episode I mean that had a massive
cultural impact because I remember that
happening because I feel like prior to
that like like I said people just they
knew about it but they didn't really
think about it they didn't really like
think about they didn't know that much
about what they were up to they knew
it's like oh that's that weird thing
that Tom Cruise is in that makes him
jump on couches or whatever but I don't
think anybody really thought about it
beyond that I don't think anybody really
thought of them as like a dangerous cult
prior to that but like I said I think
Lisa McPherson's death was like the
first nail in that coffin and then I
think maybe like the South Park episode
and stuff like that I think that like
you know made it like go into like a
much wider like a more mainstream
knowledge
so uh there was a lot of [ __ ] there was
[ __ ] there was like [ __ ] going on back
into the 70s yeah there was
there's stuff happening on the free
winds that was kind of strange back in
the 70s
um and some false imprisonment stuff and
uh
buying [ __ ] any aircraft missiles was
one of the things that our that was
rumored about them that the FBI knew
about that if they had bought some
anti-aircraft missiles to put on the
free winds like somebody's going to
attack the free winds
yeah you know I think it was red eye
missiles
which is the shoulder launched [ __ ]
man portable anti-aircraft missile they
called it an ampad nowadays there's like
they were older than the [ __ ] Stinger
they weren't as good as a stinger if I
remember it was red-eyed missiles that
they evidently is rumored to have some
because those are available on the black
market you can get them especially if
you had access to the Sea because we
were given them out to [ __ ] Rebel
groups
you know I mean some of those Rebels
will sell them right back on the black
market
but you'd have to get that through a dam
Port somewhere in a [ __ ] shady
[ __ ] Central American Port somewhere
you know
you could get your hands on something
like that
but uh
I don't know if that was ever verified
but I remember reading old reports about
that but that was before the McPherson
case
so there was [ __ ] there was spooky [ __ ]
being spoken about yeah scientists like
I said I I just think I just feel like
it wasn't like widely known yeah yeah
prior to maybe yeah you had to be kind
of like in on it you had to be
interested in that kind of stuff
specifically you know that Scientology
really was kind of like spooky
yeah it had secret military bases
but man you're hearing that you're
hearing about that [ __ ] in the late 70s
and early 80s it's like no can't be well
that's what I mean it's like if you said
that about anything else I'd probably be
like inclined to be skeptical because
most of the time most of the time like
any stories like that are usually
[ __ ] yeah but in this case this is
the one case where it's actually not
[ __ ] they do actually have all the
crazy [ __ ] that they say yeah um Danny
Rowling asks is Scientology for or
against pre-marital sex
um against in general in general you're
against sex pretty much well they
definitely do not want you getting
pregnant especially if you're in the sea
org right yeah they're
um this is not a sex cult
this is uh they're a real
when I say the word conservative I don't
want you to think Republicans or
anything they're just real traditional
they're like some out of the 1950s
mixed with maoism
and
pseudoscience and uh
corporate jargon
it's it's man this is just a perfect
product of the Cold War really it's just
yeah it's a perfect product of the Cold
War it's very cold war-ish
it would be great and they have they
mentioned [ __ ] like this in like the
video game Fallout all right it's like
something about a Fallout
it's
the military in during World War II the
military became corporate the government
merged with that the corporations it's
called the military industrial complex
and then
and then [ __ ] politics merged with
that
you had a two-party system now
Republicans and Democrats but they're
still as part of that [ __ ] same
system and they're loyal to the
military-industrial complex they're not
independent parties they're controlled
the only thing that was missing was the
[ __ ] religion and that's what L Ron
Hubbard was trying to fit in there all
right he's trying to make a religion
that can mix right in with that
structurally it could philosophy the
material behind it no it was too [ __ ]
redneck is too [ __ ] no no it had to
be a lot more sophisticated what worked
was more like psychology
and social science [ __ ] that came out of
universities that could kind of merge in
with the military-industrial complex not
Scientology but Scientology was supposed
to be that it's a corporate religion
that is kind of War alike
all right
it would have been it would have worked
had the had the source
been more educated and you know what I
mean had he been able to write better
and had it had more of a scientific
Flair to it something that where there
was some proof behind it maybe
or
but now he he just was
no he had a good team behind him but he
just couldn't really write the kind of
material
to unhinge psychology and social studies
and get them out of universities because
he tried to all right
Scientology tried with to get that [ __ ]
out of universities and get Scientology
into it but that would never work not
what not with the intellectual classes
that you have in the university life
today they'd never accept Scientology so
instead he tried to [ __ ] his shoehorned
into central Africa they tried to take
over an African nation with it one time
they did yeah so
it just wasn't written well enough from
the very beginning it should have
Incorporated everything that was out
there and used all the damn
[ __ ] Freudian type psychology mixed
with sociology and and all the damn uh
what do you call them the uh uh the the
[ __ ]
uh what was the name of those guys
these dudes that came over here from
Germany
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] emerged in with all those
guys and corporatized that and that
probably would have worked
okay but he wasn't gonna be able to do
that on his own
you know one writer can't do that
you have to incorporate other writers
and to make it look less monopolistic
like like it's coming from a collective
not from a single individual that was
where that's where Scientology failed
there's always going to be a cult
religion if it came from one man
if you want the world to accept it you
have to make it look like it was
something that came out from thousands
of people and that everyone agrees on it
that's how you do it
Frankfurt School that's what I'm talking
about he should have merged in with the
Frankfurt School of writers and made it
a little bit more Marxist in it and then
you probably would have been able to get
that into universities
and take over that way
but now that [ __ ] University
Frankfurt [ __ ] dudes aren't going to
let some goyum like this [ __ ] take
over their system it's not gonna happen
no
he was Anglo-Saxon they're not gonna let
it happen
Ben says is it the hubologist or the
hubologist in Fallout apologists are a
direct parody of the science yeah yeah
they're trying to take off in the UFO
and it spins them and kills them all
it was funny I knew exactly what they
were doing I remember you playing that
yeah that was pretty funny yeah
uh Danny Rowling said the life and death
of the late 70s 80s wrestler Bruiser
Brodie AKA Frank goodish would be a sick
show Ben says true but it's been done by
every single wrestling channel three
times yeah but it's like I don't know
anything about wrestling so it's like so
it'd be new to me
and it might be new to like everybody
else too I'm always surprised like how
many people know stuff about
wrestling like how people are like
really into it like I'm not like you
know
that's what's it's just not my thing and
it's like it's just funny to me I like I
what was I watching the other day if you
guys ever like watch that YouTube
channel company man
where he does all these videos about you
know obviously like different companies
and he talks about their history and
stuff and he's done like several uh
several ones about like he did WWF or
WWE or whatever the [ __ ] I don't I don't
really know and uh so he's done a couple
of them like that and he's obviously
like really into it it's just like funny
to me like how how it never occurred to
me that he would feel like interesting
but then like he did a couple ones where
he's talking about like the business
side of it behind it and he seemed like
he was really into it I thought that was
really funny but um I don't usually like
I usually just watch
um I like the restaurant ones actually
like I find those more interesting than
it's like I'll watch them all because
like he's I like his channel but usually
like I like the restaurant ones more
than anyone else like the ones about
like Banks and stuff like that are kind
of boring but you know
I kind of like he does a series called
what's it called I think it's all like
bigger than you know where he'll take
like he'll take something like Proctor
and Gamble or something like that that
owns like a whole bunch of [ __ ] that
like most people don't know that they
own so I I like those kind of ones but
I don't know
I don't know
um let me see Ben said uh an auto
accident isn't an accident of medical
sense is it um no well see that's the
thing
I'm thinking that if they changed it
because what else I'm not a medical
examiner so I'm not really sure like if
I know obviously they can put homicide
or suicide okay fine or you can put
accident like if you fall off your
[ __ ] roof or something like that and
then like if they don't really know then
they'll put like undetermined or
whatever but I'm assuming like accident
that would she's basically saying that
that now she thinks that it was
something that happened in the car
accident
that cause like some Pro like
complications later on so I guess
technically that would be an accident
because nobody caused it I guess I don't
really know but I still think that's
[ __ ] because it's very very obvious
that she [ __ ]
got dehydrated and like lost all that
weight because she was in that [ __ ]
room
you know getting bitten by cockroaches
and then she [ __ ] died and it's just
I don't know this case like makes me so
mad and it and it made me even more mad
because I didn't I had heard of that
case right when I went over there like I
kind of heard I didn't know that much
about it but I'd kind of heard of it
just tangentially
and then like when I had worked at the
place for a little while like not
everybody there was one of the pod
people you know what I mean so like some
of them were normal and like you could
talk to them and one of the guys that
had worked there for a long time like he
was an editor and he I think it was
um him and a couple of the other normal
people we were all out to lunch together
because we like to go and like talk
about the scientologists like we'd go
out to a restaurant and like gossip
about them uh because we were like like
I said we were the only normal people
there and they told me they're like yeah
that Lisa McPherson used to work here
like what I worked there it was I guess
it was like seven years later they're
like yeah she used to work here and
what's her face whose name I can't
remember
um yeah that was her roommate and a
bunch of people like David Slaughter and
banana Slaughter like who owned it
um you know they had to like give they
had to you know give testimony the trial
and like some of the other people that
worked there did too because they had
all known her because she'd worked there
and I was like then I think that was one
of the things that really made me think
oh my God I gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here because I started looking that case
up and then I started getting deeper and
deeper and like going down the
Scientology rabbit hole and being like
Oh my God these people are [ __ ]
insane
um you know I don't really want to be
around this anymore so at that point I
was just like [ __ ] this and it's like I
had to get out I only worked there for
like eight months but holy [ __ ] holy
[ __ ]
um
yeah
so uh I guess that's pretty much it
right well [ __ ] man I got [ __ ] work
to do down in the kitchen anyway all
right Ben uh oh Ben said there's a case
here with a little girl who died from
diabetes while in the care of a
religious Circle and people can't
understand why they're charged with
lesser charges than murder like no
intent yeah that's the thing I don't
think they stuff like that that it's
[ __ ] up
um and it shouldn't happen but yeah they
probably didn't intend for her to die
but still their actions caused her death
so I'm glad that they still have that
like negligent homicide kind of thing
there because it's like
you know you might not have intended to
kill her but you still [ __ ] up and did
some stupid [ __ ] and made her die so you
should still be held responsible for
that you know what I mean because of
your stupidity and incompetence I could
I could microwave all that uh Chinese
food we could eat some more of that
well yeah I thought that's what we're
gonna do I mean we already paid for it
right yeah I got it yeah okay that's the
thing about like that Chinese food like
I said it's 10 50. but you eat on it
twice well it's 10 well that's what I
mean it's 10.50 you get like a big huge
thing of like rice either regular fried
rice which is what I got or fried rice
with pork in it and you get a whole big
thing of whatever your name lots of it I
got sesame chicken and you get
um Eggroll an egg roll and a cookie yeah
and so I can't eat it all I couldn't eat
it all like I ate I ate probably more
than I should have you ate three
quarters of it it wasn't I don't know if
it wasn't three quarters it was it was
maybe no it wasn't because I left like a
bunch of meat there okay and I actually
like was really full and I was like oh I
probably should have stopped earlier but
I was like so hungry yeah we'll we'll
get back up again and then I'll see what
else I can do before tomorrow yeah all
right maybe I'll make some cranberry
sauce for to get that [ __ ] [ __ ] in
the refrigerator so to be ready I make
you know make the cranberry sauce yes I
do I got frozen cranberries and
everything
yeah we don't we don't we don't deal
with that [ __ ] that's just like the
gel that you can't [ __ ] no clap
yeah which is spices in it spices
crushed up pecans in it
yeah it's gonna be good I gotta say
foreign
like I said I always look forward we're
gonna have leftovers for a week I'm sure
we are that's the thing I'll figure out
and and the thing about it too is that
like even though like Yeah tomorrow's
Thanksgiving it's a holiday but I still
got like a bunch of videos I gotta do
tomorrow yeah because I'm behind Okay
and like I said there are one that we're
gonna do on Friday which like I said
this week the movie retrospective which
is actually going to be Creature from
the Black Lagoon
um normally if you're a patron you would
be seeing it tomorrow because I always
put them up a day early but we didn't
get it done so probably we won't do it
until Friday so I'll put it up sometime
Friday anyway and like I said probably
um I have a couple videos going up
tomorrow but I haven't made them yet so
I gotta do those tomorrow because you
know but I did get that if you're not on
my scare Salon site go over there I just
put up like an hour long video about
scary Looney Tunes cartoons which was
like really entertaining at least at
least if I do say so myself I thought I
had a good time making it but you know
what I mean so uh but yeah so some of
the videos like I said this week might
be a little bit late because the holiday
and because of various other things that
I had to do so hopefully
no one will be too mad about it uh Danny
Rowling wants me to do the raccoon
button like to close out the show so
we'll do that what was I still haven't
made a man said I could I'll get around
to that point of these days I promise
but all right so we'll do it we'll do it
we'll do it
it is okay
we did it's like where is that raccoon
all right so uh thank you everybody for
dropping by and hanging out with us this
evening thank you for your super chats
and if you're in the United States and
are celebrating Thanksgiving please have
a good Thanksgiving tomorrow don't eat
too much or eat too much if you want to
that's fine I probably will uh so yeah
we will be back on Friday evening doing
our side track show we're actually going
to be going out Friday night so you know
it'll be like a pre-game kind of show
we're doing Memento Mori that night so
uh yeah so we'll see you guys again
Friday night good night